michigan
has officially certified the results for
joe biden and then just about an hour or
so ago donald trump announced that he
would
allow the transition process to begin
though he's still saying
he has a path to victory and the first
thing that i have to say
he does uh he he does we we've got a big
show coming up tomorrow there's some
pending litigation that is
serious i'm not gonna pretend that trump
is on track for winning but there
there still is this i'll just call it a
very slim
possibility but uh i personally and i've
been saying this for the past several
weeks don't think it's likely at
all and uh we're gonna see how it plays
out i have no problem waiting to see
what what happens but i'm just telling
you guys this right now
tomorrow we're having a special guest
who's going to be going over
pending litigation new litigation and
serious litigation so
it might have an impact on things and uh
in other news
welcome to the tim castro podcast ian's
sick there's no one there can you you
want to show here the chair is the chair
is empty
chair stream no but yeah the quartering
is here
jeremy yeah jeez i mean i guess i don't
know why i tune in tonight because
tomorrow night's the much bigger show
but
you know i do i do appreciate you two
making me feel welcome and thanks for
having me we were like how do we kill
time until this really big
show i guess we'll ask you yeah that's
fine i'm fine hey man i'm pushing for
i'm i'm taking all the scraps man i'll
be i'll be here
i'll come out here twice a month i mean
yeah we don't have you whenever man but
uh so uh you want to just do like
quickly introduce yourself and then
we'll read the news and then we'll talk
about whatever
yeah sure um i know we share a good bit
of our audience but
you know i run two youtube channels one
called the quartering and one called mid
wesley which is more political
quartering covers like pop culture and
stuff it's only fifty thousand short of
one million so
yeah so i i know tim's got a literal
pile of gold play buttons which he makes
you look
like you there's one on the floor yeah
yeah yeah yeah i walked into the house
and i'm tripping over gold play buttons
and i'm like
tim how many cool oh he's got i got a
bunch
of everywhere like well maybe we threw
the silver ones in the trash i don't
even know
yeah balancing the table honestly don't
know where they
are i think they're in a box yeah yeah
so i'm glad to be here and uh
huge shout out to uh your entire crew
tiffany pick me up
brought me to the undisclosed beanie
compound
um yeah lydia's been uh slightly above
average at making me feel like
yes good thank you yeah tim's always
tim's always good yeah
i'm always uh frustratingly milk toast
and
stumbling over golden play buttons well
the funny thing was is you know you have
this beautiful fence outside
and then when i pulled in i really
expected you to be sitting sitting right
now yeah
right in there just like making a beer
just like literally sitting on yeah yeah
yeah but
yeah no you were busy it's too tall it's
it's like it's a huge wall we built
you know we're first one we did we're
like we're going to build a big
beautiful wall beautiful
solid concrete you can't see through it
nobody's getting on this property
all right let's uh well let's see let's
here's the big breaking news it just
just came down um
it's been updated in the past 15 or so
minutes but uh you know earlier i did a
segment on
the the feud that was going on so i
definitely want to talk about this
canvassers meeting because i'm
i'm thinking i don't know man these
republicans that were on the
the the board of canvassers to certify
the vote for biden
this guy was trying in every way
possible to make sure he would give
biden the win
even though there were serious
challenges we talked about pennsylvania
or which state michigan michigan okay
okay
uh what county uh wayne county wayne
county yeah yeah but let's uh we'll
let's
let's just uh break in news breaking
news oh sure they say the board of state
canvassers certified michigan's november
general election results monday
the board made up of two republicans and
two democrats met november 23rd
to make the vote count official after 83
michigan counties certified their
election results which includes joe
biden's 2.8 percent statewide victory
over trump
they say aaron van langeveld a
republican canvasser and an attorney for
the house republican caucus
said the board doesn't have many options
outside of performing its duty to
certify the election
quote this board must respect authority
entrusted to it and follow the law as it
is written
we must not attempt to exercise power we
do not have van langeveld said
we have a clear legal duty to certify
the results of this election we cannot
and should not go beyond that
and i'm going to stop right there and
say i completely agree with this
republican except
they're not doing their duty at all so
one of the arguments that was brought
forward was certifying means to
determine the veracity to assert that
it's true and correct
and they literally don't do that they're
just like hear the results have a nice
day rubber stamp move on well i thought
that was an interesting way to word it
too i've been following that wayne
county where they're basically saying
it's their job to certify the election
but like as you said
not really yeah but that's part of what
you do
but you didn't do the other part of the
job so i mean
to come in now and say well i'm just
doing my job this is for america
um he's scared of the mob yes right what
we saw with doxing
and family threats and things like that
yeah he's terrified
yeah so uh for those that aren't
familiar wayne county which has detroit
previously was deadlocked two to two
and uh the left and democrats started
naming where these
these republicans kids were going to
school they were getting legit threats
and then they
they issued an affidavit saying we were
pressured into this we were tricked into
it
they were promised an audit and that was
that was reported there was going to be
an audit and they're saying no we're not
going to do it too bad you lose
so now it's coming to this guy and but
here's the thing the other republican
there are two republicans he abstained
what he didn't even vote no what so look
man i tell you
you got a lot of people who think it's
the end of the world they're saying you
know if if trump does lose this and
biden gets in it's going to be great
reset it's going to be
you know all of the worst possible
things massive lockdown and the
lockdown's getting crazy
and uh if you don't got any republicans
who are willing to stand up and say no
well then dude i probably already lost
yeah and the political space i mean not
like the literal war or anything yeah
there are figures
there are a few states where republicans
stood tall
and you know i think if you're worried
about lockdowns i mean
trump's president right down right now
look what's happening in california
new york pennsylvania trying to get
people you know wear masks in their own
home
yeah it's it's what do you i mean a lot
of
times
i mean they're here the lockdowns are
here right now and
unless you have a state with um really
it seems like a republican
dominant supreme court you're living
under these rules you see that
minnesota tried to have a thousand
dollar fine
for socializing with somebody outside of
your house
and then a 25 dollar fine if you
publicly said you weren't going to obey
these rules
yeah that was uh came out of the
governor i'm sure it didn't pass but
this was what he proposed
there's like one state away from me and
it's i mean what do you mean
joe biden is not president right now
yeah where are you at do you want to
wisconsin yeah
wisconsin and then uh this is crazy in
newark new jersey
they're saying you can't leave your home
at all but apparently now there's people
saying like try me and so that we don't
know if they're gonna enforce it but
they tried saying you don't leave your
house
but let's let's let's take a look at
this uh um real quick
they say charlie spees who who
represents senate candidate john james
said the meeting
should be adjourned until wayne county's
results are audited
our position isn't that this election
shouldn't be certified
but the board of state canvassers should
only do do that when it's confident that
results it is certifying are correct
literally what certifying means i'll
tell you it was crazy about this board
meeting earlier
you had this one guy aaron van you know
langeveld or whatever his name is
this dude's clearly terrified of the mob
and um
look well i'll put it away it's my
opinion but he was doing
everything in his power to justify why
he would not try
and get this looked into so you had one
guy it was this guy charlie's
charlie spies who represents john james
and a candidate and he said
according to you know section 116 it
says you have the authority to
certify the results you know and that is
defined legally as
determining whether it's true which
means your job is to determine whether
this is true and you have that authority
to do so
this guy aaron starts saying oh i don't
see anything within the
statutes that grants me that power and
then he says it even says you have the
right to adjourn
for any necessary purpose and then this
republican guy goes
well i mean i can't just make something
up and they're like you're not you
if you want to certify the results are
true then that means there needs to be
an audit
that means you adjourn until you have
the ability to certify the results are
true
so basically what happened in wayne
county was that
there's a uh signature books i guess is
my understanding
and there were more people who have
signed in than there were people who or
there was a different amount of people
who signed and then voted
creating just a massive discrepancy in
like 70
of of the you know the voting precincts
or whatever and they couldn't figure out
really how to rectify that either right
i think that's where they stuck they
were basically like
we know this is wrong but we have no way
to it's kind of like with the mailing
ballots once they throw out the envelope
they can't right his signature
verification dude how crazy is it
that what we have learned i'm i'll tell
you this if all that ends up coming out
of trump's legal battles for the
presidency is that
we have these lawsuits and the results
then i'm eternally grateful i'm turning
away because here's what we learned
we learned that if you have uh an
unbalanced
you know uh ballot book or whatever
where you have more voters than votes
and
and less voters than votes doesn't
matter no one seems to care hey no
that's fine we'll rub or stamp that send
it on through
and in pennsylvania what's really crazy
sir thirket
uh third circuit third circuit
court of appeals uh just dismissed
trump's appeal
saying that they have no standing and
this was the suit
claiming that there were no observers
for seven six hundred and eighty two
thousand
uh votes so you know that means it means
that you can be running election
and you can straight up just tell a
massive urban voting
you know accounting center okay kick all
the republicans out right them all out
and now we're going to say everything is
for our candidate and they can't do
anything about it
because the courts have already ruled we
don't have to wasn't that guy i never
trump or two
uh the guy in pennsylvania am i thinking
of the right guy he
the guy who ruled against it i feel like
something came out where he was a never
trumper
interesting oh yeah yeah there's
something the first guy
i think it was the first uh the state
level i guess yeah yeah yeah
now trump's campaign is that this is a
good thing because it means they're
getting closer to scotus
as if like why would why would it matter
if it's scotus or a federal judge if you
lose you lose and you you appeal and
then
i mean unless they think they've got
some political clout among
specific judges well and you don't have
amy coney barrett
right now either right she's recused
herself from has she i thought she
recused herself from any
is that not true i felt like she said
she had recused herself from
that would yeah i hadn't heard about
that any type of election
i know they were asking her to and i
think she kept saying i can't give you
an opinion on okay
okay but i don't know that district yeah
she was just put in charge
he could have checked
they just did the new uh scotus
appointments where they assigned the
judges to different circuits yeah so
oh so maybe that yeah that doesn't make
sense then if she's going to proceed
over
you know wisconsin no no i mean it
doesn't mean she's going to preside over
an election case
oh okay okay yeah so the the fact that
the federal judge
kicked back uh and dismissed trump's
lawsuit
within like i think it was like two and
a half hours or something that actually
could be good
because the one thing i think that might
matter if it goes to the supreme court
is that
they might have some it might have a
bigger impact outside of just that
specific circuit so if they rule the
federal
you know the supreme court level mail-in
votes for this reason are no good
then the whole election is just upended
well let's play a game right let's say
that that's true what's what happens
there do you just say yeah we're just
not going to count
these 700 000 votes are they recast
let's say hypothetically you know this
has been my struggle is
where there's smoke as you put it you
know it's like okay well
then what you know like okay you just
throw out 700 000 votes
i don't i can't see that happening
there's there's no circumstance where i
think any rational person has faith in
our elections anymore
a lot of people are black pill which
sucks i i'm really s i see it in my
comment sections i see it in your live
chat
i see a lot of faith loss in the
election system and
and i agree that trump is doing a good
thing by
at least fighting this and exposing some
things because hopefully
these things can be corrected in
particular uh let's worry about like
fewer mailing ballots where people can
go to somebody's house and just say like
here i filled it up for you just sign
you know that kind of stuff
i've i only have faith in elections
because trump won the one in the first
place
like when when when hillary was running
i was like what's the point right and
then when she didn't win i was like whoa
he must have won by of seven million
votes you know that's how i mean i felt
he must have won by a landslide if he
had
managed because i figured they would
have tried every little thing you know
yeah trump ended up winning and then i
thought wow i guess people can really
win
well okay so then i voted this time
around and then you know now now that
you know biden's projected to win and
based on what we've learned throughout
these lawsuits yeah i got very little
faith in the election system at all
like the fact that we've got all these
sworn affidavits of impropriety in
georgia
you've got a sworn statement from i
think there's like i read like five
different affidavits
where they were saying things like i
watched them pull up votes that were
perfectly
you know not not folded no creases and
it looked like it was machine printed
what about all the post office ones
did all those affidavits go away where
people are saying i swear you know
people were swearing the fact that they
were back dating
i don't care yeah that just disappeared
we're supposed to just sit here and be
like well we have a usps whistleblower
who said they were
more than one i think it was more than
one we've got numerous affidavits out of
georgia
we've got numerous mathematical
anomalies that have been tracked even by
those like a yale professor i guess who
was like wow that doesn't make sense
and then we've got uh the voter
integrity fund which has found
thousands of voters in georgia who used
fake addresses
apparently adding apartment numbers to
commercial
addresses and mailboxes and we're
supposed to ignore everything and carry
on like everything's okay and just
assume
hey you know what this is legitimate and
come on come on man come on come on
so if if this is how it really ends then
why would i bother participating in an
election ever again
i hope people don't don't i understand
that line of thinking
but what i think is that people who feel
that way
should be really concerned about getting
involved in election reform
specifically mail-in ballots look if
you're an active duty military person
and you're overseas
100 understand why that exists but the
idea that
the fact that you cannot like there were
literally people
that were going door to door and helping
people fill out ballots
i talked to you before the show i said
people showed up at my
home looking for my wife to say like has
she voted
what were they there to what were they
doing there and and i've said before
yeah they weren't from they weren't from
around there
is what i'll say they weren't from my
city they clearly weren't there stumping
for trump
and i do think trump made a tactical
error spending too much time
trying to discredit mail-in ballots
bouts and not
uh trying to slow them stop them or
encourage his republican base to still
use them because i feel like there are
people
who didn't go on election day and then
they're like well trump says mail and
ballots are no good so i'm just not even
going to do that you know i feel like
that was a that was a trump error that
was
definitely tactical error you know that
we had like half a million rejected
ballots in the democratic primary
mail in belts well yeah do you see how
many they rejected the presidential
election yeah where are six where are
they
yeah it's unprecedented yeah so we're
supposed to sit here watching the news
i'm
i'm just citing news the these stories
about
uh potential fraud and irregularity are
coming from
like regular old news outlets local news
too
yeah yeah i guess i guess it's what they
expect of us every single one of us just
ignores it because
every single you know here's the way i
describe it to people imagine you're
walking past the building
you hear the smoke alarm going off and
you're like wow smoke alarm usually
means fire huh
so you call 9-1-1 and you say hey is
smoke alarm going off and the operator
goes
did you see any fire there's no
widespread fires
currently on record yeah right right we
have no reports of widespread fire
anywhere no but the alarm is going off
sir
unless you have evidence of widespread
fire in the building
do you want me to go inside and check
i'll tell you what happens when the
smoke alarm goes off the fire department
shows up they come outside and they go
false alarm and you go thank you
and then you feel better you feel safer
so that's that's
that's the bare minimum this is the
crave thing i'm saying
if democrats are so confident it's over
and they've won then why don't they just
say okay baby here's your bottle we're
going to do your little audit for you
and waste time and energy
and then we're going to hold it over you
well why we're blocking it yeah
why wouldn't they want to double own
trump
like this would be the double drum own
and honestly like
for all the money that our government
wastes
uh you know foreign wars and all this
kind of stuff like i don't know maybe
spend it on making sure our election's
good and not have just
one dude be like this is the safest
election in american history
but you know before any audits have been
done before any any evidence had been
out
people are just like oh well i mean we
saw how the fbi
current you know had their political
leanings we had comey
um yeah we know that there's a rot from
inside so
i think people like myself are like oh
well the guy from the fbi says okay well
all right you know like we know that
they're partisan and you know
what you know it's a really good example
of something i talk about all the time i
talk about how
you'll get some kind of evidence of
impropriety
or you know criminal activity and then
all of a sudden you'll get some fringe
conspiracy theory
everyone adopts that theory and then all
of a sudden you can't talk about the
actual problem anymore
so for example i reference like
pizzagate for instance
there are a lot of questionable emails
it seems like they're talking in code
saying weird things yeah probably just
code for drugs or something
some kind of improper act right right
then all of a sudden you get people
talking about pizza places and
and you know satan and the guy shows up
and goes crazy with the rifle and shoots
the floor and all of a sudden it's shut
up
ignore this yeah and so we have all of
this evidence of impropriety
and then and i'll tell you and i know
the trump supporters get mad
when sydney powell went on tv and she
went on newsmax and said
that governor kemp was taking money from
the communists and working against trump
or whatever i was like
right away she derailed yeah the
legitimate conversation
and don't take my word for it the trump
campaign issued a statement
yeah they disavow her almost immediately
that's what that's what they'll that's
what the left is saying
the right is saying they're they're just
positioning her so that she's you know
acting now independent or whatever and
i'm like dude listen it read like a
disavow to me
right you know exactly yeah the fact
that they had to issue a statement
saying she's doing things on her own
come on the trump campaign knows their
legal path to victory and they know what
she was saying wasn't
including it and the thing she was
bringing up about dominion
and smartmatic and all the stuff is just
too out there you can't prove it in a
court yep
so saying all these things over and over
again that's that's what i talk about
all the time
it's a it's it's it's man it's so easy
to to derail when someone's actually on
your
on your tail with what you're doing and
they're like oh
they figured it out they've they've
noticed all of these you know affidavits
swearing fraud quick
throw them something ridiculous about
venezuela poison the well yeah exactly
well and and like to be honest what's
infuriating for me
is for the last four years we were
supposed to believe that russia flipped
the entire 2016 election
you had these clips of that shill john
oliver my opinion not tim's
uh like a year ago he's like voting
machines we shouldn't be using voting
machines they're they're they're prone
to errors
and then like one year later he's like
voting machines are the most secure
thing ever
how can you do it you got to see his
tweet it was a really clever play on
words
he did a 20-minute segment where he's
like this woman went in current year and
flipped the election in two minutes yeah
come on people and i'm like
so he has a lady do a demonstration
where she walks to the machine she takes
a ballpoint pen pops it open and she
pulls out the drive and swaps it or
whatever and took her less than two
minutes
and then they issued a statement on
twitter where they're like
notice the you may have noticed
conservative media is pushing this
narrative
yeah well the truth is the biggest
problem as we said is blah blah blah and
i'm like
wait the biggest problem i don't care
about the biggest problem i care about
problems
well that's the poisoning the wealth
thing right it's almost like they gave
them something totally absurd
that some regular old horse mom you know
had a memory card the right kind of
memory card by the way it's not just any
memory card you'd have to know
oh it's a mini xd or whatever then you'd
have to have votes on it
unless i guess you could steal it from
like a democratic stronghold
but even set like it's just so absurd
this is this is the game they play
he does a 20-minute segment where he
says here's a list of problems
a b c d e but the biggest problem is
clearly a
then when you bring up whoa we found
evidence of b he goes
we said a was the biggest problem right
yes but you also said
b was a problem too so that's how
they're trying to fake back track it's a
framing device
where stupid people are going to be like
oh he's saying it's not real
oh well it's also the same thing where
they try to guess by people and say
well nobody dead voted there were no
dead voters but yeah yeah absolutely
there were yes there are
in most elections but they'll gaslight
and say like well it wasn't enough to
change election okay
well ten thousand here you got four five
thousand votes in georgia
all this stuff adds up my my position is
i i don't care if it flipped the
election or not
why are there dead voters right right
fix the problem there was a fact check i
saw this is funny
they were like no you know what what's
uh flekas
they're like flecca's put out this tweet
saying they found 10
000 dead voters you know having voted or
whatever so we did a random sampling of
50 people and found
two of them were still alive one person
was wrongly labeled it was actually
their son of the same name and yes in
fact one person was dead but this
proves and i'm like wait wait wait wait
wait you found a dead person who voted
one in 50.
i know it was something like that i'm
like shouldn't we like
check that because that's weird how did
that happen well maybe if you didn't
have mail-in ballot ballots
you know what i mean and you could go
there was this article by
vice today or the other day did you see
where they put out like maybe we should
make voting mandatory
yeah yeah that was buzzfeed i think or
buzzfeed yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know that in australia it is
mandatory though and they only get 90 to
95
turnout yeah and there were many
jurisdictions across the us with more
than a hundred percent turnout
interesting and they offered up all
different explanations tim
spare me your alt-right conspiracy
theories i read all the articles about
you before i came on the show
i was i've i've got my d radical
radicalization suit on underneath this
hoodie
just come on it never happened it
couldn't possibly happen
why won't why won't you guys just accept
that joe biden is your
supreme chancellor already i mean i mean
president president
i'm not even convinced like so look i
actually don't think
there's uh there needs to be any kind of
grand conspiracy either because a lot of
people seem to think there is like rudy
giuliani says
it appears to be coming from a
centralized place and i'm like the same
place he bought it here his hair died
probably yeah problematic but
look at antifa doesn't need a leader to
organize in different cities
they they do have leaders but here's how
it operates there's no like
national antifa guy who's like everybody
go to this place right
there are active there's like passive
and active antifa
there are antifa people who are very
very active who are vetting people and
they're the ones running the websites
and they'll be like hey we're going to
go protest in berkeley send the word out
to the other groups
and then they all show up so when it
comes to an election when you see weird
anomalies and weird numbers it could be
because where are the where the rejected
mail in ballots
rejection rates are supposed to be like
one or two percent they're nowhere to be
we're not rejecting ballots so probably
what's happening is you get one or two
people who are like this is fine to me
and we uh one of the rulings in
pennsylvania was that even though people
failed to fill out their address and
date the actual uh
the envelopes the judge said no that's
fine that's acceptable
it's like well what would it be tim how
do you how do you know it came from the
person
well because the form itself says it but
who filled out the envelope and sent it
in
well we talked about before going on air
that i received and my wife received
mail and ballots
we never requested them yeah it takes at
least in my state just a name
and a birth date which is publicly
available there are absolutely
political groups that are mailing these
things and then you follow that up with
people showing up at your house being
like hey have you have you felt like a
mailing belt well let me help you
because there have been several videos
of people like
on the porch with some poor old granny
who's like you know baking
some sort of friendship bread or
something and then they're like oh well
no okay so you want to vote for biden
right
and then oh okay and then like all this
ballot harvesting in minnesota all
that's all just
all right consumption gone never
happened yeah it never happened even
those video evidence of a dude doing it
right um this again goes back to we
strongly need to reconsider mail in
balloting it's
just too insecure the the problem is
twofold
well the problem is multi-faceted but uh
republicans are useless
completely well you know if they gave a
damn they would have done something
about section 230 in the last four years
yeah if they really care you have ted
cruz out there owning
the zuck all the time yeah it's great
it's a great for clips
but what have you done in for you guys
can they they knew they knew they knew
that this was going to happen
and they did literally nothing i am
proud to say that
um of uh i've made many predictions in
my day and it's usually i always say
this says listen
i'm not a prophet i can't pick lottery
numbers it's complicated i make profit
i make predictions that are wrong all
the time the point is i'll get some
information in front of me and i'll say
wow based on this here's what i think
and then people will click that be like
haha you thought this i'm like yeah i
thought trump was going to win a
landslide
back last october with a record economy
and moody's analytics saying trump was
going to win in
not necessarily a landslide but he wins
at a landslide without the lockdowns
yeah right oh yeah easily easily and i
don't think you could find anyone that
could
really argue in good faith against that
i am proud to say i predicted
back in 2018 that republicans were too
stupid
to deal with the issue of censorship to
save their own political party that's
cause they're all a hundred
yeah that's because every one of them
like every one of them is
what's the average at 70. josh hawley
and ted cruz that's it and they're still
in their
60s probably no no no ted cruz is what
his 40s yeah
he's like in his 50s no no isn't he the
zodiac killer though because
he's got to be in his 60s then how old
he is that's uh
how old is ted cruz this is a good time
to remember remember he liked that tweet
he's uh he's 50 he's 50. 49 49
oh he's not even 15. ted cruz is 49
that's a rough 49.
yeah and uh josh hawley is the i think
josh hawley deserves the most credit on
this
yeah he's missouri he's 40. josh holly's
40.
that's still like i mean considering i'm
not convinced it's stupidity to be
completely honest
i think it's a combination of apathy and
uh look the the the republicans are for
the like
there's there's establishment
politicians dominating both parties and
they always have
and they all hate trump the thing is the
never trumpers
who formed the lincoln project were
free agents essentially political
commentators and you know coordinators
and
strategists or whatever so they had no
problem being like we don't like you
know donald trump
but then you get all these republican
candidates actual politicians who are
like i'm up for re-election in two years
uh-oh what do i do i better pretend to
like trump as well
but then give them the opportunity and
they're going to be like get rid of him
because a lot of those guys didn't they
didn't get punished either there were a
lot of never trump or republicans that
kept their head down and just kind of
pretended to play a ball but you knew
who they were
and they didn't pay the price i mean the
republicans dominated in the
in the senate and house votes i mean
what would there's 50 open seats
or 50 toss-ups and they won every one of
them something like that for
2020 yeah i don't think they they didn't
win every single one but they dominated
whatever it was they didn't they didn't
win them they didn't win the uh uh
the majority i guess i'm just talking
about democrats classified classified a
toss-up
well yeah the polls were all broken yeah
yeah but anyway
the point is if you've got fervent
you've got two you've got two
two kinds of democrats well no you got
three you've got the corrupt crony
leadership types
like schumer nadler pelosi biden you've
got the ultra woke progressives
who are in my opinion more interested
with celebrity and being angry and
that's like the squad yeah and then you
have the rank and file
or whatever that's 80 of them right yeah
and the republicans are all the dole
whatever
yeah yeah so most most of them are just
like bump like it reminds me of a bunch
of just like
you got a bunch of people walking around
bumping into each other and just about
like just mindlessly walking in a room
that's why i want term limits can we get
term limits please
yes i'm sick of having these people
right you know in positions of power for
50 unchallenged as a gerrymander and
change your religion and never get out
of there
and and and i think they need an
injection you know if you want to make
the term limp for
fine but can we just not have these
people that are in in the senate in the
house for
50 years because they never change i've
heard some good arguments against term
limits
one of them we had someone on the show i
remember it was they said well maybe
maybe with sean parnell can't remember
they said but you need people who are
going to get in and who are going to sit
on committees and gain seniority
and and have experience and i'm kind of
like you can get that in four terms
right yeah
you can't i mean yeah i'm not saying it
has to be two but i mean i'm also saying
there's no shortage of people that want
to get rich in politics and most of
these people like you point out
are more interested in celebrity just
like reporters are now did you see that
hilarious mike pence uh press conference
the other day where the reporters are
like screaming at the team
left the room what's going on here
and they're just like what are you my
favorite is i think it's caitlyn collins
of cnn
it's like literally a minute after after
he's gone and then everyone stops and
then it's just the last minute she goes
you're complicit and ruining democracy
there's like something like that
on twitter dude that was one of the
funniest videos ever
mike pence is like goodbye and then they
all start just yelling rabble rabble
rabble yeah yeah pence is
gone and they're like it's like
that that shows you know what you know
united said about that that was their
death rattle
yep it was then you know when people are
dying death rattles the
the spitting everything in their throat
the gases are escaping so they go ah
that's what it was without without trump
they're done
well do you think dan was gonna have a
crap about jim acosta no no he's over
he's oh he's going to write a book could
you he's going to write it he did write
a book well he'll write another one
about how he was solely responsible for
trump getting involved
and then that'll be journalism like us
yeah yeah yeah right we're
we're we fight the power we're really
hard-hitting stuff i don't know they
might go after biden
no way you don't think so no way no no
come on i mean look i think
i think we were talking about this
before probably most people secretly
agree cnn really the bean counters at
cnn wanted trump to win
oh yeah yes there's no doubt about it
and they are going to suffer
ratings oh they're done they see t's rep
reportedly wants to sell them
yeah right because they know they're
peaked get rid of it get rid of it quick
before we lose value potato yeah i was
watching
i think it was uh i was there was on
market watch so it was like a
non-political
financial site and like att is buried in
debt
cnn is at its all-time high but don't
you think a buyer would know that
like buyers like i'm not buying this
thing you know you mean you milked trump
for four years and now that he's
he's on the way out you want to offload
that crazy no
way wait till they have to report every
every new couf
passing on joe biden see how that goes
for them
well you think they'll lose the tickers
that's how my local it's like on the
side they have like
234 thousand deaths and you'll see it go
boop like 235
you can just see i'm like yeah they're
getting all like
you know excited yeah wait two quarters
we'll see what happens with uh with
trump but uh that's that's the other
news
uh trump tweeted this out trump tweeted
i wanna thank emily murphy at gsa for
her steadfast dedication and loyalty to
our country
she has been harassed threatened and
abused and they do not want to see this
happen to her her family or employees of
the gsa
our case strongly continues we will keep
up the good
fight and i believe we will prevail
nevertheless
in the best interest of our country i am
recommending that emily and her team do
what needs to be done with regard to
initial protocols
and have told my team to do the same so
trump has
opened up transition it strongly
strongly suggests that trump is
is is nearing the end of uh of his legal
battle in terms of like viable paths
there there is still some litigation and
we're going to be doing a big show on it
tomorrow tomorrow night
so i'm not going to say out right right
now like i know the media wants everyone
to say just admit it it's over
yeah i mean it's as close as we've been
trump is not
doing well that's as close as you're
gonna get to a concession from trump
i think so his concession speech goes
something like this
uh well you know i love this country and
why you know a deeply
flawed voting system cost me and he may
be right but he's not going to come on
concede that's not trump's game no he's
going to be like i won this election
right i won yeah but yeah joe biden is
stealing it and i have no choice
right right i'll see you in 2024. right
right yeah yeah but oh god please
yeah like when he is if he on his way
out the doors it's like
we were talking partner assange oh yeah
pardon uh pardon
snowden yeah declassify area 51 and say
and then just say you're running in 2024
even if he doesn't plan on you're like
i'm coming back and just no no no need
for years
trump needs to say he's retiring
completely and then just go silent
for a month you know why every one of
these fake news outlets these media
companies
will be gone and then he comes back with
his own news now i'm back baby
trump tv i'll trump all 24 hours yeah
and then all these other media outlets
are sold and
and you know they laid everybody off and
it's over dude the
the founders of vox there's three two of
them left already
they cast out they can't yeah they can't
yeah they're not doing
fine they're not they're doing just fine
but they cashed out this was them
slapping the slots max bet
and then finally they you know once they
were like okay okay
i'm out that's we're gonna get get our
coupon and go to the go to the lady at
the counter and get my money and leave
yeah and then yeah that's that's exactly
what's gonna happen to a lot of the
mainstream media you're gonna see
a lot of consolidation especially on the
mid-tier stuff
i mean if you look at i'll even a lot of
you know i don't watch ratings
on mainstream television because you
know no offense lady but like
both people at this table get more views
a day than cnn
so like i don't on tv right well i'm
saying like
their average viewership's a couple
hundred thousand no no no cnns
see like this this is the thing cnn and
msnbc in the past couple of months
have they've like they've taken the the
trump sponged and squeezed it until it
turned to dust
okay so their ratings did really really
improve okay close
close combined we got him beat probably
i mean tucker was getting what two
million viewers
five five five million until all right i
was wrong
until fox news turned on the trump legal
battle
well when they started when they it
started when not poor tucker
tucker was uh being petulant about not
getting sidney powell i believe
yeah and and when fox news caused errors
called arizona now
to be fair correctly at least right now
that rubbed a lot of people the wrong
way because because no one else
didn't play it no one else did it
appeared in play at the time that pissed
people off
then tucker i feel like
he got a little a little salty that she
was going on newsmax and she wasn't
right
and look she didn't owe him let's say
hypothetically she had the silver bullet
she's not going on tucker carlson to
give him the evidence that's for the
courts
well apparently she did she said she
said she did she said she sent him an
affidavit and offered a mathematical
expert who can talk about
some of the other data that they've
they've pulled up okay and i guess
tucker said that never happened
so what about that what about that usb
drive of all that evidence that whatever
happened to that weren't people asking
about that
i don't know remember it was like he
received the package and it was open
what happened to that i don't know but
that was the hunter biden thing yeah
yeah what up what what was that tucker
what is this it's just he was like
he's like you know our courier our
documents went missing and it's like
did you you didn't just email it was it
the only copy
why was that listen listen listen i'm
familiar with
you know operation security and how to
transmit information and sensitive data
and stuff
i i would not send my usb of sensitive
information
sources over what do you do ups right
yes no usps i think it went to the us no
no i think it was ups
was the ups yeah it was they did an
investigation i think and they found it
on the floor or whatever
yeah wait wait wait hold on hold on a
minute dude yeah super secure you've got
super top secret documents all of your
evidence on hunter biden
you put it on a usb put in a package and
mailed it out through us
through ups you wait what why don't you
just email them
on top of that if you were going to do
even that you hire a courier
so that it's like direct point-to-point
courier or like you said
um there's a million secure file
transfer websites that
yeah yeah like what are you doing that
doesn't make that and then
when he was like we did find them and
now we're dropping the story because we
shouldn't be going after people's
children
yeah yeah dude yeah morally
grandstanding after
there are a lot of people that believe
that he got got that he
you know maybe somebody was like hey
this isn't it but tucker
is fox he he pretty he's now yeah
yeah he was for a long time hannity was
for a long time before him it was um
who's the super right-wing guy bill
o'reilly bill o'reilly yeah but then he
didn't know how the moon
no like he didn't factor the tides yeah
that was funny
yeah isn't it really crazy evolution
like from bill o'reilly to be like sun
goes up sun goes down you can't explain
that
no can't it's magic and they're just
like magnets the guy in his show was
like we explained that 500
years ago but then you get tucker who's
like
not you know dumb and no
yeah he's smart but then yeah yeah this
hunter biden thing was weird and then so
is the sydney powell thing is weird
yeah that was uncharacteristic of him
the hunter the hunter thing was really
bizarre
because i mean the left-wing media has
zero problems going after don jr
or ivanka trump they have several
problems with that so what about this
dude
who's getting foot jobs while smoking
you know he's
got a crackpot in his mouth yeah and
he's got like allegedly
there's many chinese monsters listen
listen listen
here's a guy who we got a photo of him
with a crack pipe in his mouth
yeah like explicit videos and then when
they call it for joe biden there's
hunter right there on stage with his dad
it's like
dude whoa man yeah like we just saw
photos of this guy you're gonna act like
none of that happened everything's okay
this is the creepiest time what about
the email
that the guy literally thanked him for
connecting him with his dad
and they're just like well there's no
smoking guns sir
oh are you saying the interval is fake
you know you know michael malus
yeah i gotta quote this guy too much
because he's a smart guy huh he said
he thinks that some very bad people got
data on how much
people are willing to accept yep i'd
agree with that think about
the sheer audacity of everything that's
been happening with like
hunter biden and now with all of the all
of the messed up irregularities
and literal evidence of voter fraud i'm
not saying widespread but there is
literal evidence of what sworn
affidavits we know it happened
and it's all being ignored and we're
told to shut up and it's like supposed
to do
70 73 million people voted for donald
trump
i'm i could be wrong about this but i i
believe he's the first president
to lose re-election but gain votes can
you
can you i can't live in a world where i
have to accept that joe biden got
significantly more
votes than barack obama that's crazy
yeah i know i can't buy it and
people freaking loved he was a celebrity
obama he was
in his in 2008 in 2012 he liked like
four or five million votes
i think obama was the first to lose
votes and win re-election like typically
when people won he was running against
him
i mean that was an easy dub for him yeah
who's voting for mit and by the way
against romney is like voting against
like a mannequin yeah
he was like a super rich trust fund kid
he was like republican.txt
yeah i hate it like i hated him and he's
also a total turncoat too he's like
we should prosecute trump and blah blah
blah like get out of here mitt
you think they're gonna try and lock
trump up no just like we he never locked
up hillary either unfortunately
i was i was thinking that that's that's
that's my main line of thinking nobody
prosecutes
it's not happening but the way i put it
but think about how insane they are
like maybe maybe joe biden one joe biden
said he won't do it but i'm like
i always felt like the chance that trump
would actually lock up hillary was you
know
zero i knew it was zero two yeah but it
was funny it was a good meme right
yeah i kind of feel like the chan like
the probability that the left
tries to lock up trump is greater than
zero yeah maybe it's one percent maybe
it's two
they tried if you just try then i even
made
they might you know twenty percent when
donald trump won and then he was doing a
rally he was like
no we're not gonna you know we're not
gonna lock her up that was you know that
was fun but it was only a big campaign
slogan of mine for
six months but yeah but but but trump's
supporters were like you got it trump we
trust you whatever you say
yeah now joe biden wins and he's like
turn it on
pressure and so have you seen it can you
can either one of you say yeah he can
say it how do you
know not now we can't try to say it fast
yeah true in another shabbat the
pressure
yes oh truer words have never been
spoken yes
true in an enemy of pressure yes uh and
batacaf care yes
so he's gonna he's gonna mutter and
mumble and the left is gonna be
screaming and banging on walls and just
like shaking tables and vomiting all
over themselves demanding trump be
arrested
there is going to be a section on the
left that still
the same people that didn't get over the
2016 election
they won't get over trump they're still
gonna screech about him
every time he tweets this is why i think
twitter actually won't ban him
right right right because they need
twitter people made careers as trump
reply guys
and like i know people who made money
it's crazy yeah but they destroyed their
careers
well yeah you have no credibility left
yeah i knew a guy who was actually a
producer for some big news outlets yeah
and we were friends and then i saw him
just replying to trump saying really
dumb things
i messaged him and i was like yo dude
you gotta
stop doing this listen man like if you
want to tweet
talk smack about trump call him out be a
quote guy
right quote tweet and then say like
here's the source fact check but just
replying with these stupid hot takes
so cringe dude and he gained like a
hundred thousand followers
sure was super excited who all abandoned
him oh absolutely
yeah the moment he stopped doing trump
reply hot takes and tried doing serious
stuff people started smack talking him
they started ignoring unfollowing and
now not only has he lost the reply guy
grift
now he can't get hired anywhere because
they make fun i'm like you're that guy
oh dude i can't hire you are you not you
have no credibility
yeah that was a funny existence i always
thought that
like replying directly to president
trump was a self-admit
admittance that you have tds like tds
one way or the other
we talked about like there are tds
people that are like
super like trump can do no wrong that's
gotta have a different name they're
still directing sycophant syndrome yeah
yeah
tss tss toxic shock syndrome i don't
know oh yeah let's talk
syncophant i think implies a higher
level of understanding what you're doing
okay so this is this is more like trump
drone syndrome
yes yes zombies yeah trump drone
syndrome
well there are them and they exist but
like
i would see people reply like every time
i see people that i follow who shall
remain unnamed
like replying directly to trump and i'm
like
but but look look i think it's fair to
say that there is a
if you take all of trump's voters 73
million
there is a small fraction maybe that's
the second most votes ever
yes yeah right so most votes for any
sitting president
in an election yeah and it's the second
most for any candidate
so i think out of the 73 million you
maybe have a million that are
the trump drone like trump can do no
wrong he's always perfect he's always
the best
but most of his voters are probably like
well you know
trump's got problems here and there
because i do these uh you know like when
i do videos i talk about what's going on
the ultra die-hard trumpers are like
they're really mad at me they're like
posting
memes and they're making fun of me but i
get dms from people who are like yeah
man i think you're totally right
some some high profile and just like
regular one of the male trump supporters
and they'll stray straight up like i
think you're right about what's going on
so here's the point
trump supporters mostly regular people
but
of the people who voted for biden i
would say the overwhelming majority are
trump derangement syndrome
well a good chunk of them and like union
guys straight blue
guys are there you know no i don't think
they voted for biden my dad did
my dad is a machinist a union guy in
wisconsin
yeah wow does he know anything about
biden no he doesn't know anything about
he's just
he's just blue trans pacific partnership
blue his job is going to be gone in a
week
he retired last year and he um
you know i don't i don't get political
with my family there's no point you have
literally nothing to gain
but like there are guys like him out
there yeah he's like yeah i just saw i'm
like dad have you ever voted red
nope like really you voted for mitt r
uh for uh um who ran against bush jr
um gore gore yeah you voted for
al gore for dukakis he voted
look he was born in every blue candidate
since
1970 he's voted for it and like
look it's you know it's my dad whatever
you know i mean like i love them
but i mean people like that exist where
they're like punch that blue
blue vote the party and yeah that's true
blue no matter who
yeah well and one group of of blind
voters that
i think biden got that hillary lost
were disaffected bernie bros i think
yeah that disaffected bernie bros broke
for biden
more than they broke for hillary i think
when when biden got
when when bernie got screwed the first
time they just didn't vote
this time they were like okay we'll just
vote for how old are you
37 37 so we had uh vashon
and i think he's like 26 right 26 yeah
so during occupy wall street
when p when hundreds of thousands of
people took to the street to protest
barack obama for a variety of reasons
joe biden as vp vash was 16.
and so he's here and he's arguing in
defense of joe biden
and i'm i'm like i'm i think i mentioned
this like i can't remember if it was
part of the conversation we talked for
like four hours
and i said occupy wall street was a
protest organized against the federal
government in 2011
three years into barack obama's
presidency and joe biden
and they were talking about the bailouts
being bad in the big banks and they
opposed the wars and the drone bombs and
all that stuff
why would you vote these people back in
he was 16. he didn't know anything about
that
yeah i'm not saying to be disrespectful
i'm saying quite literally you had
people
who were 10 years old yeah you're right
and now they're 20
and they're like yay 78 year old you
know neolib
bankster i think warmonger i think he
probably relates to joe biden because
they both like them young i think right
now but the uh yeah the um
yeah i think yeah well yeah it's funny
because
you know without getting a little too
off topic but it's funny that like
when you realize you're kind of old yeah
i'm almost i'm closer to 40 than i'm 30
and i still feel like i'm 20.
you know except for when i get up in the
morning then like then
you know sometimes i have to get up now
in the middle of night to pee that's a
new thing
in the late 30s i didn't even have to do
that i've been i've been skateboarding
since i was 13.
and it's really weird cuz i'm 34 now and
i still skate and i hear the stories of
people saying like man once you get in
your 30s i'm like dude i feel literally
the same
maybe it's because i'm part asian we got
that like we look there's something
there
yeah i don't know are you taking on are
you on that um did alex give you some of
those pills what is that what is that
stuff super
super male 1
i don't even like taking aspirins for
headaches i don't like to
drink water and you know maybe i eat too
much uh uh
combos well you eat that like a 16 year
old since i've been here
no tip full exposed temple explosives
here's what i've seen in meat since i've
been here a handful of combos and a
fruit roll-up
yeah yeah i just said it
yeah i did eat that weird i ate that
weird
healthy vegan pizza thing it wasn't bad
no it's okay see what you're thinking
pizza
yeah with some with some cheese very
normal but uh uh
what were we talking about i heard you
like to cook now is that is that no not
really i mean i have breakfast i don't
know
put eggs in bacon oh okay what were you
talking about before you decided oh oh
yeah
something got him off track boys yeah
being old and uh
young people not understanding what they
just voted for i can't i can't believe
i was just so surprised all these
progressives are like we have to vote
for joe biden
why what happened to progressives who
were 18 when i knew him they would never
have voted for an establishment democrat
yeah that's so weird that never would
have happened it's crazy to me that
that all these occupy people were split
in the middle between some of them
a bunch of them are trump supporters
that makes sense to me
trump opposes free trade agreements
trump was basically a bull crash in the
cathedral
these occupy style people who are
pro-biden and i'm like
i see them they weren't they weren't pro
biden they were
anybody but trump yes i think why well
but here
here's the thing though i think that
what happened in 2020 was very similar
to what happened in 2016
that there were an absolute ton of
anybody but hillary's
yeah which is why trump won some of
those states that you know like
wisconsin's
thin margins you know people in
wisconsin weren't voting for hillary
clinton right that wasn't happening
um so when you get like your status quo
old white guy then all of a sudden
they're like oh okay
yeah joe biden's chance he's like my
only chance to actually win because he's
tried what like three times
he's so yeah yeah but man you know the
media
they they they battered trump up for
years just
getting anything they could out of him
what's gonna happen
that's why i'm saying trump should go
totally dark i mean he has been for the
most part he basically has he's kind of
chilled out this week
he's chilled out this way but they've
got all the lawsuits to report on so
imagine if imagine if joe biden's
inaugurated
trump just nothing nothing
he just fades off into obscurity again
after declassifying area 51 files
because we need to know
we do but yeah i mean they would crumble
and it wouldn't
it wouldn't take long it wouldn't take
long no they would first first they
would write trump hasn't tweeted all day
something must be up
yeah the next day they'll write it's
been two days yeah then everyone will be
like
that then you'll get a theme where
they'll be like it's acceptable to write
about because everyone's asking
questions
and then it's like one week on where is
donald trump and they say we all know
he's the most racist and vile bigot
but now he's going dark is this part of
a secret plot trump's going to be
sitting on a beach sipping a pina colada
or whatever
diet coke yeah well the
yeah well my part my thing is they're
still going to go after trump supporters
yeah that's still going to be yeah
they're still going to go you know
they're still going to go after the
because you see it in hollywood some of
the worst vile garbage humans on the
planet in my opinion
saying you know like i'm still
disappointed that 71
million americans are racist 73 million
yeah sorry
like you got like cold air up there then
you get all these then you get like
these um
uh cold bears they're all dumb the
the yeah like they're so dumb they don't
even do anything
well they totally do though like okay
allow me to
i know this probably isn't like this
isn't gonna get you in trouble but
nothing
grinds my gears more than these brits or
like foreigners coming over here
and getting late night show hosts and
getting rich dumping on america
you got trevor noah you got uh uh james
corden
you got all these people uh um john
oliver oh i shed a tear i was so
powerful to be able to well he's an
american citizen now i'm pretty sure i
know he voted yeah but he made like a
big deal about i'm like dude
the only reason you're popular is
because you're just another vehicle to
deliver that mainline tds
that the far left audience needs we we
we have our pro-trump brits and
canadians
you know we do joseph watsons and uh
piers morgan i think right yeah but he's
kind of in the middle he like
yeah he goes both ways yeah he was it's
it's really weird too but these guys
aren't hosting television shows
right piers is but but he's but he's
he's in the uk
and so if you're in the uk and you're
writing articles about trump that's fine
and to be fair politics of watson doing
a youtube show where he talks about
everything from modern art
culture to stuff like trump i think is
fair as well
when you are not american and you come
here and host a show where you tell
americans what to think i'm kind of like
bro you
you don't know is trevor now american no
south africa
but he got american citizenship yeah of
course he did so i'm fine with that
of course of course totally fine with it
i mean literally if they're not
if people who aren't citizens who are
commenting oh okay sure well i'm just
saying it great
it grates me a little bit when a guy
comes from a country where like um
white farmers are being massacred
talking about how america is so bad
you know maybe you know talk about some
things that are bad
you know on both sides of the the aisle
you know these guys are so partisan that
you know look at least sean oliver was
he was uh jon stewart he was definitely
left
but he would also like he was it wasn't
so bad he wasn't so like lazy and like
oh
his hands are small kind of jokes yeah
my issue is predominantly we have we
have uh
it's not so much the lighthouse
necessarily i'm not a fan of john oliver
because i think he's plastic and
formulaic
yeah it's so like every single joke is
the same and it's kind of like uh-huh
and especially now that they're doing it
from home and there's no there's no fake
laugh track it's kind of it's actually
it's like a horror movie remember the
first like month when they ultimately
all cut trying to do their show on
youtube it was
just just the camera was like trying to
pause for a laugh and there's just
nothing and it's like but i don't what i
don't understand is like trevor noah
does his show
from like this weird corner of his room
or whatever yeah it's like dude
like we i'm i'm in my house right now
like we've got paintings we've got like
we did
we did the walls up all nice with like
this vinyl you know
well these dudes have real money like
they have they have like
wealth let's fake authenticity like
we're at home with you
i'm just like you yeah look i haven't
cut my hair
but they still the crazy the crazy thing
is
like when you do your segments you don't
script anything do you no yeah
that's like the real political
commentary on youtube most of the the
bigger channels
or i should say the like political
commentary channels that are original
authentic
yeah not scripted yeah there's a couple
of like video essay guys out there
and guests that do a good job but most
most of it is pretty off the cuff
you know but then you look at samantha b
and john oliver and trevor
i'd rather not no thanks yeah i'm good
yeah samantha bee is hard
she's the worst yeah yeah if you see her
tweet the ap tweet out tomorrow's
international men's day and she's like
oh
what a great day to stay inside because
men suck
she's just hardy that's the thing right
it's like
uh you know right now i've always been
you know middle of the road for the most
part during occupy wall street the left
loved me
yeah because i was like showing what was
going on and the cops were shoving
people and hit people
and then you know i had a bunch of
right-wingers always saying like fu
yakipa you blah blah
then when the trump stuff happened and
i'm like oh the media is lying about
this all these trump people are like oh
wow
you know tim's so great in the left is
like turns out well isn't it isn't it
funny how like you can remain the same
but who's in power changes
yeah therefore the perceived allegiance
changes the funny the funny thing now is
i have trump supporters calling me a
grifter and i have
leftists saying oh tim's finally come
into a census and i'm like no
no you're all like the tribalism is dumb
if it's true
and and i i'm just going to say what i
think but i said this is going to happen
i was like
if if if it goes bad for trump and i
start reporting on it
then i know the right's going to get mad
at me yeah the reality though is most
moderates like
the regular people from occupy actually
became trump supporters and always have
followed me
and then the moderate conservative types
who are seeing the same thing are dming
me saying like i think you're right
about what's going on and stuff like
that
it's just always the the hard like
antifa types in the far left are like
tim's a traitor and now the right is
like tim's turned his back on trump
yeah well you you and you know this like
look yes
the tim pool is a fence sitter meme is
true it's in fact
i ask people you know what's the number
one thing you want me to ask tim about
first of all
why you were so easy on vows and so hard
on alex the other the second one was
that that's that's not even true i was
yelling at vaush
i couldn't i couldn't watch it was just
looking at him he looked dirty
and i'm i hope that this actually it's
not fair to take shots he's not here but
we were we were yelling like we were we
were we yeah
yeah we we're exchanging words and like
and then we'd like set her
simmer down and then we'd be calm and
then outside yelling we did that for
like four hours
with alex i thought you were pretty
rough on alex but it was
you had him on a short leash i should
say i'll say that i think he was on a
really short leash
but as also a fellow content creator i
can totally understand why
i don't i don't you know i don't like i
i brought him on he could say whatever
he wanted
you know and not really like like what
do you mean
well i'm just saying like he can't say
whatever he wants that's not him though
i didn't i didn't i
i told him he can talk about what he
wants to talk about i'm not going to
talk about what to say right right i'm
going to disagree
you know i think like i think people
might understand that like i probably
don't agree with him on a lot of things
you and alex yeah but i'll tell you this
you know when they pulled the episode i
immediately said alex and michael come
back on the show we're doing it again he
was pissed
and then it seems like it's simmered
down right alex was pretty pretty salty
about it
i talked to him right away when they
pulled it down yeah because when he
what happened with alex jones was that
he made a comment about firing squads
yeah yeah and don't repeat it yeah no no
i
i
thought he said something about it it
was like uh
but not an actual thing it was a
sarcastic
sarcastic call for this herd yeah and
yeah so
but everyone everyone here after the
show like we we we all
kind of thought i figured that they're
going to get show you somebody from
youtube was watching it guaranteed
yeah like it was only after the show
that alex said that's not what i said
and then i was like oh cause after the
show you guys reacted immediately
when you yeah yeah and mike even reacted
yes i mean both of you yeah so we all
kind of thought that he said something
that he shouldn't have said
yeah and then i immediately contacted
youtube and said yo this is a mistake
they said we'll get back to you i
emailed them again we'll get back to you
yeah in the meantime i said
you know open invite for alex to come
back on the show he said he would come
back as far
as but he's got a family and he's got
his own job right so we ended up having
michael back
and uh i i don't i don't you know alex
owes me knows
no owes me no favorites right right i
just wanted to make sure like
when youtube pulled the show people were
like you know oh tim's not gonna fight
back whatever i'm like dude
come back on the show why wouldn't you
it would be the one of the most popular
tim cass ever why would you not want to
seriously
have that
yeah yeah i want uh i feel like they're
you know i have my lines i have my
boundaries if it's arbitrary and a waste
of
time and energy they can get me banned
then i wouldn't do it like saying
certain names or whatever
but if it's an issue of doing an
interview having a conversation with a
guy who's been
maligned for the most part then i
absolutely will be like no come back
that's bs
and then we would literally bring up
that's not true that was a mistake they
amended youtube amended their statement
they basically said at first he made a
comment about wanting a thing
for a specific guy once once we realized
that wasn't true
they issued a public statement saying he
just made a blanket statement about
executions
yeah but wasn't he like saying is a as a
metaphor
didn't he mean like these well that's
what he's so all all i can say is
yeah i don't wanna yeah yeah well i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna repeat it but he
said i agree with with bill gates about
a specific thing yeah right
and then he uh uh on his show said it
was a metaphor for you know vaccines or
whatever right right right right that's
how i but i understand
you know how it was perceived right it's
not about it's well i
i i didn't he we thought he he said
something different yeah
so he talks fast and but the issue is
that youtube is sitting there shaking
with their fingers
yeah like say it yeah oh he did it
three hours and you only had one second
that's pretty incredible i mean that's i
thought at least
they would like tell you all right bro
just delete it but we both know that's
not how communicating
what most people don't know is even tim
with his
700 or 800 gold play buttons that are
outside yeah
he doesn't even actually bricks in the
backyard it's just these gold play
buttons the whole house is just layered
yeah
yeah he has a he has a bunker downstairs
that's lined with them but
the um the they don't care about you
like they cared about that episode but
like even having a million
i said this to people all the time i'm
like i have you know
i i'm just not as many as tim from like
people like bro can you just help out
can you get email
youtube to help out no no i can't i have
750
000 subscribers after tonight after all
of you subscribe almost a million
but the they don't give a [ __ ] about me
i can't i don't
i can't call anybody i remember
pewdiepie complaining about this
you all know who pewdiepie is because
he's like watching him yeah
he's the number one youtuber and he's
complaining constantly about them
yeah i can send you anything can call i
can get
i have a i have a double review process
so if a video gets demonetized
i submit it for review and then if they
confirm it i can submit it again
manually oh i don't directly to google
that's that's something see
that's the timfoil stock you want to
know you want to know exactly what it is
it's that i am a
traditional liberal fed up with the
democrats
and the left going nuts like many
liberals who have found themselves
questioning what the democrats are doing
and realizing that they're out of it and
trump is the best bet
thus like like youtube is essentially
the way to describe it is there's like
the overton window but can imagine a
wheel right a half wheel
and then you've got far right right
center left and far left
they want the wheel to rotate right and
then what happens is when they ban
a right wing youtuber it makes tim pool
liberal become timpool centrist
right then when they rotate the wheel
again tim paul centrist becomes tim paul
right wing
but what they want right far right wing
no no eventually what they want is
all of those people goals for tim they
want all of those people who are on
youtube and users not to leave
so they're like we need to make sure we
have a liberal that they'll watch
and so not every conservative likes me
but youtube promotes you know and
and you know they've taken my channels
off the blacklist that's surprising
so they're clearly watching well i've
talked about here's some inside baseball
that's fun
fun for people because all those people
out there love to hear about youtube
analytics
but the there is a very real thing
that channels can go under review i've
i've
got it down so my channel recently went
on a review it's always 23 days
it's happened to me twice this year and
i predicted the exact end of it and sure
enough
so starting like november 1st i think i
stopped gaining subs
for like wow 23 days and i had been
gaining a thousand to 2 000 every single
day for like three streams
yeah stopped and then 23 days later
which was like last week
started again what and and that happened
again back in august
so my guess is they also put channels in
this like
borderline content yeah right well we
need to review we need to you know he
made a video where he made an edgy joke
so now you're in the
i i get i have this thing that uh it
pops up from time to time where
i can't get monetized right away or
demonetized at all
so it'll say pending pending review i
might always say that every time
yeah and then and then i can't challenge
it i can't do anything until
you know 20 minutes or you know half an
hour sometimes it takes hours
this past week it's been very slow
brother did you get a strike
for alex jones we got a warning yeah i
started my warning too so now you have
no more warnings
and that means if we get another strike
we can't do anything for two weeks
the good news is two week vacation uh no
it's not a vacation
no well i i asked them because there's a
there's a circumvention rule
where if your channel gets a strike and
you can't upload you can't upload to
another channel
oh is that true yeah but i was told
specifically
if you already have different channels
that do different things okay
it doesn't apply to you well hopefully
everyone would just be really generous
in the super chats tonight
to you know just in case you ever get a
a day off or something like that you
know by the way i took a day off a
couple weeks ago like after the election
because i was like
how'd that feel man i rode my bike 32
miles
that's not a day off it was right brutal
it was it was it was intense my legs
these roads are dangerous out here that
was the trails yeah it was the uh
yeah it was trail so uh yeah i guess it
wasn't a day off
let me ask you about this no here's
something that i think that
people might want to know as i take over
the interview here the um
here's here's something i often try to
describe to people
um that you must feel even more than i
do
in the golden handcuffs of youtube right
like if you take a day off
like for guys like us who the video is
relevant for 24 hours
for the most part yep so if you take a
day off you make zero money
you know there's not a lot of carryover
a little bit a little bit yeah but
you're like doing videos every day
you'll see like you'll make like like 20
of your revenue is from the previous day
right it'll carry over in the morning
but like two or three days off and then
you're down to nothing
yeah how do you because i haven't
figured it out yet i'm just working
every day
do you take sundays off no yeah i do i i
don't take sundays off but i film for
monday
no i work longer that's sustainable uh
probably until i just die i guess
right at a very young age my heart
explodes
yeah i don't know my
i hope it's on a live stream because
that would just be it that would be the
way we're about to launch another show
why not i mean who needs sleep so here's
how it works no one i wake up at about
7am
yeah and then i immediately pick up my
you know pick up my phone and i start
going through
notifications and messages and emails
reading twitter then i get up and i you
know go about
the quick morning routine you know three
in the morning on
uh tim cast right normally well so i do
uh i do three at 6 00 16 6 15 and 6 30
a.m p.m i have ten one
four and then six six fifteen six thirty
those are the shorter segments that are
you know
yeah yeah but uh uh short for you about
ten minutes they're
they're about that is super short yeah
they're usually about 10 minutes okay
and and i do that because they're
usually stories that don't have much
bigger context around them yeah yeah so
throughout the day when i'm pulling up
all this news i find stories where it's
like it's actually a big
story and uh but i wake up about eight i
work
from eight to about four and then from
four until about six is exercise
and food yep and then we start getting
ready for this show so we
you know the guest comes down we'll
start we'll hang out we'll talk we'll
you know kind of warm up the
conversation
and then we do this show until usually
around a little bit over a little after
10
yeah and then i probably fall asleep
around 11 or so you like kind of wind
down figure out where our guess is going
to be staying and everything like that
so what we're going to do is that period
between 4 and 6 where i'm usually just
skating is we're gonna hire someone to
film a vlog
we're gonna do at the house skating
video games shenanigans
don't you think you need that decompress
time though you need that time
off but so here's the thing when i
before we start doing this show
you know what we'd be doing right now if
the show didn't exist talking about this
exactly so what would happen is like we
i would finish my show and then we would
be sitting in the game room with like
sodas or chips or beer
talking about all this crazy stuff and i
was like why don't we just film it and
start a show or whatever
yeah yeah why not work why why would i
why would i not be working right now
but it is it becomes an obligation and
that changes everything
right and it's not fun anymore i mean it
is fun well when i'm here yeah yeah yeah
you're you're doing pretty good you know
no but but but it is fun it's fun
like we just sit down and hang out like
we were talking even before this yeah it
was like
usually to tell people like save it save
it don't say it don't say yeah
we gotta go back up we're gonna do the
show and so when i took a day off that
one sunday right my bike
i'm just like i get back and i'm lying
on a bean bag and i'm like this is
boring
yeah i want to complain about stuff my
wife is my camera
yeah my wife is concerned that
i may just die at my desk which by the
way
like that's the true dignity like i want
to die at my desk
you know i don't want this like
retirement you know sitting around doing
nothing
but i do i do wonder like i worry about
you
because i know what it does to me and i
only work six days a week
and i don't do a nightly show but you
seem to be holding up all right i mean i
saw like what it was like 40
60 bottles of adderall downstairs oh
more than that no
that was just the main i had a migraine
early i i worked through it i won't even
take
it yeah yeah you were griping about that
when i got here
migraine was i not really but i
mentioned that i'm just trying to add
some spice
come on yeah i was wailing
yeah around my brain was like ah
give me the the pills that give me
modafinil or no pro vigil it's called
yeah that is no super migrant stuff it
makes it so you have to sleep
oh cool oh give me there's one episode
of uh
american dad um where they have like
this hypothetical cia pill
so like stan's taking it and his and
like his wife finds out and she gets
pissed because he's like up
playing beat man like video games all
night long and like it that would be
nice to not sleep like she i think she
starts taking them too and then
she's like yeah yeah like i got snipers
take it like astronauts take it because
it like you just don't get tired or
whatever or something like that
i can't imagine you can do that long
yeah no i think i got it uh you know i
planned this all out i said
years ago when i was like when i started
advice i asked them i was like can you
give me the point where i have no free
time
and they're laughed like because they
like i i'll tell you men they're lazy
not the higher ups they those guys work
to the bone but most people were just
lazy yeah like some sometimes they
didn't even show most people
are lazy yeah not just vice people
that's that's that's a
that's that's aren't you bored you know
don't you want to like build a like
build a tree house like
jump off a building i don't know i don't
know i just think you're going to be
different
like i i don't i don't like look down at
people who enjoy downtime i'm not saying
you do either
but i don't i hate down time like we
both play world of warcraft right
no i don't anymore i don't have shadow
landscapes channel
came out today yeah and i was like oh
man i got a four hour layover in detroit
i'm gonna play and then instead what did
i do i brought a webcam and a microphone
so i can shoot videos from there
well so you know what you know the thing
is like one of the challenges now
with everything's going on because we
talked about this a while ago like
maybe maybe we should do this show as
like maybe once or twice a week with
with special guests instead of just
trying to like
trying to do something every day yeah
but with the kobet lockdown
this is one of the few industries that's
surviving and so
and that's just survival i know yeah
yeah and now the lockdown's getting 10
times worse
well but there is there is this issue
with the lockdowns when the lockdowns
first happen revenue plummeted by like
60 70 percent
because a lot of the ads that come
through are small businesses yep
so if you live in views were up but cpms
are way down
yeah trash and so it was like my revenue
slashed heavy but
i had a job yeah like business was still
growing it's hard to gripe
right when you're still you can we can
stay home we can be locked down and
still grow and
you know that's the other thing it's
like why would i like now is the worst
time to stop doing this
because there's no jobs there's never
going to be a good time to stop though
that's
the thing and um there i mean there is
you know how much money is enough when
you die
joe rogan got a hundred million dollar
contract a hundred million
at a certain point you gotta be like i
don't know what is but it's not the
money
man it's never the money no i know i
know like i i you know it's crazy like
people i had a comment i po so i we just
finished the skate park yeah it's it's
the grove that's awesome it's built
i dropped in did a couple seconds seven
twenty
three foot round yeah yeah it was you
know i had mad momentum i posted about
it like so what we wanna do is we're
going to do a new show
which is going to be the house the fun
you know we we've got
like we've got hunting ground we've got
uh deer blind towers things like that
we've got a bunch of fun stuff we can do
skateboarding we're going to do crazy
stuff for the winter like i'm talking to
these construction guys i'm like
we might build the longest grind rail
ever done just like the breaker record
yeah
like literally like a half mile long
just ridiculous
just like hopefully it's downhill yeah
yeah it's downhill but then it has like
a few
instances of where it goes up so you can
you can control your speed better okay
otherwise you're just going to start
going faster yeah you had terminal
velocity yeah but so
so uh you know the goal with that is
we're going to do an online store and
all that stuff but i had someone comment
and they were like how do you afford all
this stuff and i was like bro i used to
work for disney
like i worked for i worked for disney
like and people are like
do you think that working for disney
you're poor like disney pays stupid
money
and so you also have very generous
supporters and especially those that are
here tonight beautiful all beautiful
definitely that's true yeah super chat's
legit yeah super and they're all super
from super attractive
people and they're some of the best
smartest yeah yeah and it's actually
they've scientifically proven this that
um not only are people who give super
chats more attractive on average
but that actually by giving a super chat
you become more interested i've read
that
yeah yeah that's a joke by the way it's
not true
they're going to be like tim's trying to
default oh no it's written on the
bathroom wall up here i don't know it's
crazy
yeah but there's a uh considering the
lockdowns are about to get a hundred
times worse
do you hear about the uh you really are
do you hear about newark the mayor said
you can't leave your house at all
and now people are like can you do that
i don't think you can do that that's
unconstitutional right
yeah but in europe they're doing it and
i think they don't have the same
protections we do they also don't have a
first amendment there either
right or a second or a second yeah right
yeah yeah in
in greece i think if you want to leave
your house you got to text to the cops
like hey just like one ask permission to
go outside hey bro can i go get yeah
i gotta go to the store and get some
rubbers but here's the here's the point
right
it seems like everything that's being
done right now in the us is has the
as the only effect of destroying the
economy do lockdowns work
no not really no are they working in
europe
no right did they work here well here we
are again with major spikes
right do masks work technically
that's the answer i don't know if i
could say this well about answering that
so according to there was there was a
study out of denmark that said if
everybody wears masks it will work the
problem is we can't get everybody to do
it how do you get yourself well and you
see how people wear them right
you you leave them yeah they ram it in
their pocket or they put in their center
console and they leave it hanging
they don't wash it it's just i see these
people that they're hanging from their
rear view
or it's under their nose yeah right yeah
they don't even understand collecting
all the boogers or
or like joe biden he takes it off and
coughs into his ears
and then puts it back oh my god wait did
you see rudy giuliani's booger
oh no no congregate oh rudy
okay okay i watched it i couldn't
believe it i can't he blew his nose into
his handkerchief
and then you watch him take it booger
side out
and wipe it off he like wipes all over
his face right yeah
rooney oh he had the hair dye and booger
gate
like a one 24 hour span like
yeah man that's tough that's tough i
mean anyway
yeah with the lockdowns now that we're
moving behind booger gate yeah okay
you never really moved beyond it yeah i
couldn't just learn to accept it
uh what are they doing they're saying
don't go to school yep
but the cdc said that's yeah go to
school it's fine
why are they doing it i don't know but
i'll tell you this if the kids can't go
to school parents can't go to work
well that's a really damaging part
especially in on the middle class
because it's not like like look if mom
and dad are together which is
exceedingly rare this year
or these these days and they both work
you probably can't afford to have one of
them just become a stay-at-home mom
or dad especially in new york yeah you
know like
what if you're rich well yeah don't
matter right the people making the
decisions have the money
you know they're like oh we'll get rid
of the house made maybe dude every
everything we're seeing
is all uh contributing to the largest
transfer of wealth from the lower
classes
the middle class lower class to the
upper class look what the money business
has made
but but that's stock price so basically
when you shut down all the small
businesses and allow the big box stores
to stay open
what you're saying is what little money
you have left has to go to the major
corporations
and insult and injury your business is
now destroyed so you'll never have money
again
so the best part is i hear these people
saying like well the government should
should give a stimulus and i'm like
yes what that will do is either
it's going to be deficit spending which
will devalue the dollar
substantially and give all of that to
major corporations right
you know so that's basically what's
going to happen well it's all going to
go to amazon walmart and like
targets but think about the vaccine
right now
they're saying that there might be i
believe they're gonna do a mass
deployment of the vaccine free of charge
because the government will cover the
cost well yeah of course
where do they get their money so what
they're doing is it's a massive transfer
of wealth from poor people to major
pharmaceutical companies yeah
yeah so what people don't realize is
that the us dollar
essentially functions to guarantee that
someone will do something for you
if you devalue that then you know it's
worth it you know becomes worse they'll
do less for you
that means the money you have in your
bank is becoming worth less and less the
more the government claims
they're going to spend this money and
guarantee your labor to somebody else
well yeah but i mean you're also i mean
the concept
that you're espousing is not super
complex
but explain that to somebody who's you
know living paycheck to paycheck
you know that's the problem is like you
try to explain it and
it's like they have the reality of
unfortunately like well i need to pay my
bills right
my work's closed down i can't you know
my kids aren't you know i can't go to
work because my kids have to stay home
uh so forget it you know well let's just
mortgage the future
for political clout now instead of
what they should do in my opinion i'm
not a doctor
i need to accept the rates i need to
move on with life i need to do like a
simple animation
like make a new channel that's just like
explaining things
wait was it you know an animator do i
there's one in the house right now
oh yeah i know oh i know a ton of
animators yeah but what i'm saying is
the idea is imagine you have like five
people and they each trade
you know one like a b c d and e
and they and those those those items
circulate
the the the guy who makes the letter a
trades that the guy who makes b beat it
to c etcetera then you introduce a guy
who just makes money
he literally controls the flow of money
yeah now he's sitting there and he can
buy
any one of those objects with doing no
labor
if you need like so so basically what
happens is people people don't seem to
get this i know most people
watching probably do because i think
politically savvy audiences regular
people don't get this concept
that if you have people freely trading
money among themselves or fully trading
their labor among themselves
and then one guy sits back and says you
know
give me control of making the money and
i care not who makes the laws
right he doesn't have to lift the finger
ever because he can just press a button
on his printer and then say here's money
you want money right and they say yes
he does whatever he wants from that from
whoever he wants people don't understand
that when the government just
does quantitative easing or prints money
or whatever they're basically saying
we are guaranteeing to the world or
whoever we're giving this money to that
you
will do work for them well isn't that a
dollar not even backed by
really anything anymore yeah right yeah
yeah right so i mean like you know
ultimately you look at
ian's probably in his room right now
listening going no the federal reserve
the federal reserve oh maybe you should
have came to work
yeah the um you know i think ultimately
i live in a small town you live in a
small town
no i don't live in a town at all well
true like legally i guess it is
well i mean yeah we have more bears
around us than people
sure yeah yeah well once and dear
beantown gets uh
beanieville gets incorporated because
you're getting up there now for
population
that's true the you know you don't see
it
because these governors who are making
these decisions and i'll just talk about
wisconsin i i won't
disparage any other governor although
i'm sure they're all crap
you know this evers doesn't come to
where i live he doesn't come and see
these local businesses these bars
that have three people doesn't care he
doesn't right because he gets paid
either way you see this with gavin
newsom goes to some french restaurant
mask list
this is the same dude in the door yeah
indoor who said you're supposed to put
your mask on between bites yeah that's
his thing
between between bites at restaurants
california medical board
yeah and he's out there with um you know
all the who's who of people that are
profiting off of this
and and you know look the the the the
disease is real and should be respected
but also like let's not destroy our
entire country over it you know i think
that's
where most people are right now and you
have a lot of people out there who
you know mom and dad can't afford to
have some kid there are a lot of kids
that you know they don't have
laptops and they don't have a webcam and
they don't have all this stuff
there's going to be i think what that
we're sitting on the
a pile of potter kegs yeah like we i
called it a potter keg last year
with black lives matter and anti-fun all
these riots
now we got them all stacked up you got
regular americans like trump supporters
in huntington beach
this is what's crazy because we don't
even know where we're at with the
president like it's looking like you
know
trump's i don't know where we're gonna
end up he's still gonna have supporters
right no matter what happens huntington
beach they're defying curfew
they're going out and they're protesting
at same time you still
you still have excuse me black lives
matter you still have a lot of people on
the left
that are going out and angry and so
a lot of the riots we saw earlier in
this year
were for black lives matter and george
floyd but a lot of people contended that
being locked in a in a you know concrete
cubicle in new york city for months with
nothing to do you can't go outside made
everybody kind of lose it a little bit
well it made it way worse
it gave look in wisconsin we were locked
down during that time and i was like
oh you mean i can go outside because
it's a political protest
sweet blm baby exactly you know it's 70
degrees outside
i want to go see people and what people
did yeah so now you've got
this pending lockdown joe biden said
he's going to uh well look i'm going to
listen to the scientists on this one
and his one of his lead advisors
osterhomes had six six-week national
lockdown
is the funniest part about that start
interrupt but he's actually said it
would also
heal the economy right right what you
can't do they're mutually exclusive
in in in the view of the great reset it
will heal the economy yeah right
turn it into a communist economy a
command economy i'll owe nothing and be
happy about it that's right so
here's what i see yeah what the heck
you're going to lock down all these
people again no stimulus
no no plan a lot of them are being
evicted they're starting to freak out
then you start destroying the business
of people on the right everyone's going
to be ready to burst
yeah so i saw there was there was one
story in reuters where they went to a
town and asked a bunch of trump
supporters and one guy said if trump
gave him the signal he'd get his gun and
he'd be ready
and i'm like that is scary there are
people like that
but there's on the left too yep there
are so what do you think happens when
they lock everything down and destroy
everything to an extreme degree
good you know honest working people's
businesses and livelihoods are gone
they've lost all ownership of property
because
they're they're just not allowed to work
anymore well they tell the government
tells you what you can do in your own
house
you got to wear a mask in your own
castle you know so you get these people
bottled up to the brink and then the
left just snaps
they go out they start smashing things
again we get the
the george floyd riots times 10. what
are these regular americans going to do
are they going to sit back and just be
like the government's there for me are
they going to say finally
no the government is not doing anything
well i think it's going to come down to
how individual law enforcement also
uh enforces this kind of thing so in
wisconsin
uh i've talked to officers who shall
remain unnamed i live in a small town so
you just know everybody
and they laugh they've said openly i'm
not enforcing this crap
you know go to the pub have fun whatever
you know we're trying to stop crime
right not people from like living their
lives now if you have police forces
who start to enforce this stuff then
you're gonna end
up in a situation where you're gonna
have regular citizens armed against the
police
which that's a huge uh they're
outnumbered
significantly yeah in that scenario and
especially when you talk about rural
cities
which is i think where it's more likely
to be prominent where you have
you know small law enforcement but right
now
thankfully from what i can see both in
pennsylvania look that governor
spaghetti in new york
his own police force his own police
force won't enforce his crap
they're like no dog we're not enforcing
it so i you know i hope
that um the police force just says
no we're not we're not this isn't
fascist you know we're not going to
oversee what people do but then you got
what knew some like no ten pound turkeys
these people ten pound turkey i don't
know yeah it's scary to think about
all i know is that i'm ready dude it's
it's like some kind of hunger game
situation where
these elites are all dancing and
laughing and drinking epic acts they can
vomit eat more while they're telling
everyone else to go suffer
for them you know yeah well that's i
mean you know
i don't know anybody who's like a super
left i do
i have a couple bernie friends but
they're even they're not dumb
like they would admit that like
governors like pelosi with their salon
yeah yeah gretchen whitmer yeah
beetlejuice out there
like having a pro binding rally no mask
but actually
cancel thanksgiving because you know
beetlejuice says so
like people can't eventually people
gotta just say no
like i'm not i'm not well up with this i
think i think it'll happen
i mean i we saw in huntington beach
people go out but i think the real
solution shout out to a lot of latinos
out there too the new the news did not
like that yeah
they did not like that doesn't doesn't
fit their narrative
i think this this ends when people just
go like if everybody
who had a business in an area just
opened their business like normal and
said no
right there's no violence there's no
protest there's no blocking streets it's
literally just people go about your
business like normal
yeah and that's the kind of protest that
works because government is all about
confidence in in the authorities
you know well that's what that's what it
is in the small towns like where i live
everybody's open you know there's like
occupancy limits sometimes you go to
like uh if you go into the city
they'll have people outside with
clickers like making sure that right
number of people are in the store
where i live nobody gives nobody cares
like you go i go to the pub
same people there now there are people
who want to stay home and that's their
right
totally i would never make somebody make
fun of somebody who's like
being super cautious that's your choice
we have a couple of deer that are
hanging out outside eating grass and
they have clickers too and they're like
making sure and looking at us
yeah right get out of here you dear you
can't tell me this isn't exactly six
feet
uh yeah there's um there's a tweet of
somebody in michigan who is whining
about a local business being open i
don't know if you saw it say when
it was like total care and tweet like
she had like secret footage from her
cell phone and a restaurant like look at
this restaurant
oh yeah that's right all these people
yeah yeah like nobody cares nobody cared
right she got completely demolished
and i'm like okay you know like faith
restored
that like all right you know yeah people
are just saying shut up yeah
like dude we see we see the governors
ignoring their own rules
i'll put it this way well first there
was a gallup poll that found
33 percent are now saying they're
unlikely to follow these rules
and earlier in the year most people
agreed they would when
when you have politicians they lead by
example
when they say everybody it's a pandemic
we have to stay home
and then they're seen at a restaurant
with no mask i'm like they're not scared
at all
no of course they're not they're the
ones with the access all this
information all these medical experts
and they're not scared why should i be
well in wisconsin i can say like the the
general consensus is simple
it's like the the the daily news that
the mainstream media
would have us convinced and again i want
to be very clear the virus is real and
you should be respected but i will also
say
if you watch the mainstream media you
would expect bodies stacked like cord
wood
in the streets well it's not there we're
we're you know the hospitals are you
know it's because we we
we had something really really bad
happen earlier in the year here's
here's here's what i think happens well
new york did get out of control you know
new york is still somewhat out of
control yeah but i think what happened
is
two things good thing they wasted all
those elderly people to free up beds
though am i right well no but
that's one of the things earlier earlier
on a bunch of these governors put sick
patients in nursing homes killing
tens of thousands of people yeah and so
now
that they're not doing that again look
at the numbers the rates are
right yeah right and then they go and
then they go we've developed new
treatments
it's like also you stopped killing old
yeah you you stopped taking a grenade
and
like pulling the pin and tossing it in
but this is uh propublica
a left-wing publication wrote about uh
cuomo being responsible for like six
thousand five hundred deaths
they they had a coffin in the street and
then people were taking the leaflets
from his uh
from his book by the way we should
congratulate him what was it
yeah yeah yeah yes
this is this is such an insane world you
know you know what man
people like to talk about how like
something happened in november of 2016
yeah where like we got hit by a meteor
and now we're all in
some kind of you know alternate like
hell or alternate dimensions
some people i love this conspiracy that
on election day the large hadron
collider fired off something and like
open a new reality yeah and it's only be
getting crazier
it's so insane right now that you have
cuomo getting an emmy
literally killed thousands of old people
like
he did it's it's his call it's like 6
500 counts of negligent homicide yeah
i'm not even
i'm not even trying to exaggerate or be
hyperbolic he put sick people in nursing
homes when we knew
the old people were the most vulnerable
right right and this is pro-publica
reporting on this this is a left-wing
like non-profit news outlet
it happened and they give him an award
for it
and everyone's just supposed to sit back
and be like okay yeah that was a pretty
good move
yeah yeah yeah well it's actually it's
actually really really cool that he used
his tv
you know presence to to win an award
while killing yeah
enough with the politician celebrities
please yeah i know we had a president
who was a celebrity
but like you know when i have aoc he's
like i'm
i'm totally like you it totally sucks
i'm going to play among us
like i don't i don't want to see you on
twitch i want to see you on capitol hill
doing your job
and just wait till thanksgiving you wait
to one of these police people break into
someone's house because they see six
cars in front of it
like that's gonna be one of those type
of yeah
um litmus tests of how people shot heard
around the world could you imagine like
hiring a plumber
and instead of fixing your toilet he's
playing among us and talking about how
like
right there's really great ideas for
inventions for plumbing that like
if people would just listen to him like
it's really hard to like you know get
this new kind of technology for like
i i want to make this pipe i'm saying
you know we should have uh
you know new new pipes for everybody
right and you're like dude dude dude
the toilet's right there it's literally
pouring water poop water onto the floor
can you please well that's that's
exactly it like this
to be fair to be fair she's a freshman
congresswoman so there's not a whole lot
she can do
i guess well so i had a question how old
is she
20 what is she 28 she's she's 30
something right
because i looked it up and dan crenshaw
is 36 years old and i don't think he's a
freshman but he's really he's a freshman
too
he is as well isn't he dan crandall's
getting stuff done she's 31.
wow she's 30. so dan crenshaw's only a
few years older than her
and he's out there making speeches and
he's making sense that's true that's
true a huge respect for him he's he's
not
dance 36 among us he's not playing
twitch games yeah seriously that's a
good point he was on seal team three
yeah dude he actually yeah he
he's the second third most popular
twitch streamer two or fifth
but twitch is all like far left you know
what i mean yeah it is so we when
they're either apolitical or far left
when we were when we were starting the
show we had uh some conversations with
some like
network people yeah who were very savvy
and they were you know talking to us and
i was like i don't think we're gonna do
twitch
no it's not just about that it's far
left it's like they'll they'll ban
people
for like reasons well you should be
doing this as a dear person
yeah yeah yeah give me that if she's in
the scratchies
but if we if we uh uh you should be
simulcasting you should be doing that
yeah i don't know it cost you nothing
although you have like potato internet
here so i don't know if you yeah we do
have potatoes
yeah yeah i got good news yeah oh one
breaking news
in in three weeks we will have gigabit
yes
and then we will have streaming in 4k so
you're gonna so you won't have it for
the big show tomorrow
no no it's and this is crazy because
like when we have some of these guests
i'm like don't cut out
because it happens when you live in in
the bumpkinville in the mountains you
know well it kept happening during
during your alex jones episode
everyone's like yeah no they're like
they got you yeah
my mom texted me she's like i think they
shut you down yeah like no
calm down calm down well yeah i'm like
i've watched plenty of episodes where
the internet craps out like i'm sure
it's just that
yeah yeah but but maybe it's not maybe
this time
yeah yeah let's uh let's do super chats
yes if you have not already smash
the like button smash it because it
really does help and did you know that
probably 40 percent of you aren't
subscribed to tim cast's channel that's
like
that's crazy too that's yeah right
that's a really sad number there's a red
subscribe button right below the video
just click that easy to click no but uh
actually
is it are those my tricks similar for
you like yeah about 60
likes 60 are subscribed or something
like that right about yeah
yeah people don't unders i i i'm saying
this sincerely
the more people who subscribe to you and
keep watching if you're a consistent
viewer and you're not subscribed
that's like it hurts you and it hurts
youtube yeah yeah right if you if you
subscribe and you watch every time
youtube goes whoa
super engaged really good content yeah
yeah and so
uh a lot of people don't know that and
then they don't like either and and this
is true a lot of people used to think
that likes and dislikes are the same
they're not
nope dislikes destroy do not get
dislikes
well they're engagement but it's not the
same no it really does shut you down
yeah so uh i've talked to some people
google's not supposed to say man top men
yeah
yeah and they were like we can't tell
you anything about how the system works
don't get any dislikes yeah and i was
like okay all right
okay and you can see it too you can see
it because what happens is if you get
too many
youtube stops recommending the content
yeah i buy that yeah that's why
guys like us survive on recommendations
because like really you're not showing
up in the search algorithm and
your subscriber count really usually
like from notifications is like four
three to four percent so you really need
to be like on a training topic that
youtube then recommends your video so
yep yeah or just if if people
consistently watch your new videos
youtube will keep recommending that's
true too but that's what i'm saying if
you subscribe and then keep watching
youtube goes like wow we're so impressed
look at all these people we're gonna
send them another gold play button
yeah gold that's right all right let's
see
energized and uh engineer isaac
i'm sorry i heard a rumor that they were
only going to read the first
200 super chats tonight 200. we got way
more
i need to get another drink then because
we got way more
no i think we probably read like 25 to
we read this month
we can well because we we go we usually
do about a half hour to read as many as
we can so we definitely can't get
uh everyone but uh here's another
important one batgoat says tim you rule
sub to the quartering oh that's good how
many subscribers do you have right now i
have like
900 no check out your phone oh okay
check out your phone while you're
pulling that up
i'll pop it on super chat all right
i definitely don't have it i have nine
hundred and forty four thousand seven
hundred and forty four
yeah so come on guys 56 koa subscribe
to the quartering yeah what's your
what's your youtube.com slash the
quartering
it's like slash c slash the quartering i
think it is something like that
yeah search for the quarter and
subscribe he'll get over a million and
then he gets his go his own gold play
i know and i'll send it to tim so he can
add another block yeah
dan says brie larson 2024. yeah
she's got my vote let's see uh
zach edwards says i started watching you
both around the same time near the end
of 2017.
i have to quote michael scott and say i
feel like all my kids grew up and then
married each other
i love you both the first time you've
been on the show
yeah yeah hey well you know kyle booth
says i just want to say that i truly
enjoy both of your guys's content to be
honest
i would never have found you tim woolf
if it was not for jeremy from the
quartering wow oh you're welcome
thank you i'll take one of those gold
play buttons with you guys it's actually
in a gift bag when we leave i hope yeah
you both do a wonderful job and thank
you so much for what you guys do i
listen every day right on
tim tim poole's tin foil beanie says
sidney powell is hugh
oh all right i didn't realize that
archimedes says jenna ellis tweet as i
said third
third circuit has granted our appeal and
we already have one case from pa pending
before scotus interesting
but when was that tweet from because i
know that they got granted the appeal
from the third circuit at 11 a.m
and then at 3 00 pm they bounced it yeah
yeah yeah
but that again that could be because it
goes straight to the supreme court
yeah it could have it could have
something has something could have
changed since by by knocking it back it
i don't know i don't i don't know i just
tell you the way i see it is like dude
wouldn't you want the win at any level
if you could get it right if you went to
court and the judge says you win
wouldn't you be happy like i don't see
why it has to go to the supreme court
michael says you jeremy you great yo
jeremy you great this is for you but it
will be for tim now lol
oh that's all right well mostly for
youtube
density uh density coop says please have
joshua phillip from the epic times on
your show he has he has info on dominion
that hasn't been in the press yet
and he was the first reporter to report
on china's organ harvesting of the falun
gong
he was one of the early ones that did
report on yeah and they say
and newsguard says bad things about the
epic times i know well you know what the
problem is their ads are a little spicy
oh really we've got the truth that no
one has
yeah and then michael goes on to say yo
jeremy shadowlands is out what are you
doing here do you need
don't you need to play wow no i don't
you know what really is disappointing
i'm
i'm going to leave a yelp review before
i leave of the the
beanie hotel the internet is subpar so i
probably won't be playing
that's it the ping here is like 10
milliseconds all right then i'll place
it and the upload rate is pretty good
all right well then i'll be playing too
you got a gaming laptop or something
yeah i do oh definitely definitely i got
to record videos after the show
oh okay no bad yelp reviews let's see
where are we at bill says yes the
republicans are largely just big
government corrupt globalists just as
bad as the democrats
they love helping the democrats get
power because their political role is
controlled opposition
you know the way i see it is the people
who got in for the longest time
democrats or republicans
don't want to work no they don't want
jobs they want to maintain the status
quo right
no i don't i don't think it's political
i think it's like dude if i can get a
paycheck and sit around doing nothing
sign me up it's not even that much money
though that's a crazy thing no no but it
is after the fact they're all
millionaires yeah that's not every
single one of them like half
yeah end up becoming millionaires and
they do books and they do this and that
and they get
donations for their whatever right right
after after you leave
you still have access to capitol hill so
you can easily get a job as a lobbyist
then you get paid a ton of money
or you do some favors or whatever they
just want to go in there and they want
to you know
lindsey graham wants to fist-bump kamala
harris and then pretend like he's
actually fighting back against you know
machine or whatever
right they just like please can i have
the keys so i can sit in my lounge chair
again i don't want to work
i feel i feel bad for them i really do
yeah i do too my heart goes out to them
yeah
bill h says according to wikipedia
dominion bought sequoia voting systems
from smartmatic in 2010
interesting you know what's really funny
is you know joe biden has the chairman
of smartmatic on his uh transition team
that's not interesting
in fact that's super not surprising so
here's the he also has all these big
tech
facebook people and yeah yeah here's the
deal man
come on man here's the deal joe biden's
got a guy from a company called smart
maddox smartmatic
is a court there's a wikileaks cable
from cablegate back in 2010
that i don't know who this guy is or
what this assertion is but it was a
diplomatic cable saying that they
believe
smartmatic is actually owned by elite
venezuelans and they run
through shell or corporations what's a
diplomatic cable
so these were communications between
diplomats and
oh cable is like a form of communication
yeah like a document like a
communication gotcha and so wikileaks
it was called cablegate 2010 or whatever
and they they dropped a bunch of these
diplomatic communications
and it was like the the media was
shocked it's gonna ruin foreign
relations all this other stuff
but nothing happened one of these
documents is uh it's a cable talking
about how
smartmatic was actually they claimed to
be a us company but were actually
started by elite venezuelans i'm not
saying that's true i'm saying that's
just a document from 10 years ago that
was released by wikileaks
either way did you look at that though
because i watched cnn and they said
actually you're not allowed to read
wikileaks
no only cnn is no it's okay uh you could
either work for cnn or
be an actual uh agent of the federal
government i mean i mean
i didn't read anything yeah yeah okay
okay yes you're allowed to read these
things
i just want to protect you tim i don't
want to get in trouble
i was always funny whenever the occupy
people would be like during
they'd like tim pool's a cop i would go
i didn't spend four years at the fbi
academy to be crazy
well i don't know four years is probably
a long time or whatever yeah right here
to be called a cop
thank you very much yeah it's doctor
it's doctor yeah
bill says uh trucker you mean tucker
trucker and anderson cooper are ca
cia agents enough said controlled
opposition just two sides of the
intelligence deep state government coin
literally
i don't believe it i know anderson
cooper interned at the cia
and then he ended up leaving he's a news
reader though anderson cooper
you know i think he's just i i don't i
think he's just an elite he's a
vanderbilt
yeah you know he's a rich family and
he's birds of a feather flock together
and they you know they hook each other
up he's a fun
a fun quick that was tucker yeah totally
isn't he like the air he's always had
money candy bar fortunately
he's always had a seinfeld joke yeah
yeah yeah
nobody yeah you're two now i know you
are old
i was a little kid there so deep lore
about me there was i used to have this
claw machine channel long before they
removed all these claw machines
anyway the today show flies me out to
explain to them
how call machines work so go to new york
and wait wait
you did yeah so then i go to new york
and i'm on the today show with some dude
who works like two days a week and we
have to film something in his house
i'm going somewhere with this how these
people are paid this guy works like one
or two days a week we go to his house
which is like
a penthouse and like a super tall like
the guy's a multi-million
like if you're in the news media you're
getting paid yup
even if you're like a low-level
investigative reporter if you are
maintaining the matrix they pay you well
to do so yep yeah
yep when i worked for uh vice i was i
laughed when i first walked in that
building
because for one thing most people like a
lot of them wouldn't even show up
because they didn't have to why would
you because they work they work on their
laptop and so they're like oh they email
me and so they just
not come in one day and then when i
found out they were getting paid like
some of them were like advice doesn't
pay that well a lot of them were getting
like 35 to 40.
i was like you mean to tell me that's
their first job though right first job
out of college
yeah they they're writing about brad
pitt's junk and like doing drugs at a
rock concert and they're listicles
they're getting paid double what like
laborers are getting paid
like working class guy and you know when
i worked someone getting 12 bucks an
hour these people are getting 17.
yeah amazing that's america the american
dream
but it can't it can't it can't exist
like that forever you see
you know these these companies buzzfeed
you know they can't keep printing money
advertising is changing and they're not
changing with it
right v city says just want to point out
dukakis beat biden in the 87 prime
deep lore yes one drop says f this i am
not willing to give up on the best
president in my life
for the most corrupt non-president ever
biden will
end by pocket lives and start new wars
karma's a b
and depression is your future oh bayern
is going to be like
oh he's yeah he's he's done he's you
think obama
droned wait do you see what biden does
wait till you see at least
at least obama had like cognitive
faculties
so when they came to him and said uh mr
president here is a list of uh
the here's your disposition matrix
that's what it's called the disposition
matrix the kill list
and a mama would go oh i think uh
we gotta kill uh this guy right here
yeah joe biden's gonna be like
yeah and they're gonna be like just kill
all of them matrix uh yeah all right
we'll just handle this here's the deal
true none of the shopkins how many of
these marks are malarkey
this this guy zizi says jeremy
indianapolis native here sorry you got
sucker punched in my town
if you roll through again i'd be glad to
back you up love your content bro keep
it up all right
hey it was a great trajectory point for
my career to be honest with you
nick smith says hey guys i'm a 25 year
old vet always loved politics
after finding out that our troops were
lied to i'm gonna make a go for office
f the establishment hey good luck good
luck man thank you for your service
i do caucus that's a good that was a
good one bill says real talk
1 million trump supporters marched on
washington a week ago i am not
advocating for civil war but they were
literally talking about uh about taking
dc
what happens is trump supporters remove
biden at the inaugurations
what happens if um it wasn't a million i
don't think
i think the high estimate from trump
supporters was two hundred thousand
and it's what the media said it was like
ten or twenty thousand two the pictures
looked way bigger no but even even
leftists were saying a hundred
okay that's strong that's strong but but
they were saying it to like make fun of
the trump supporters like you said you
got over a million when only 100 000
showed up
in a lockdown era a hundred thousand
people showed up that's
and but what people got to realize about
conservative presidents right now is
that they're all from rural areas they
gotta fly
when when you get a democrat you've got
philadelphia baltimore new york newark
you've got a bunch of blue cities
that are within a couple hours driving
dc dc itself but for trump supporters to
come from
wyoming west virginia from you know
middle middle of the country
states montana yeah it's really really
difficult i mean
you know missouri or even money illinois
yeah like spending money to fly
you know like hey if it was happening in
milwaukee i'd be there but you know it's
a 2 000
plane ticket and you know it's real yeah
lone wolf says i believe the perceived
censorship on social media is actually
the pure result of activists whose
literal job chosen or paid is to report
content collectively they overpower
that's true
yeah that might not be the only issue
but i think
what the left does is they have
organizations that will find content and
mass flag it yep
so a guy probably walks in a room with
like a hundred people he goes all right
guys we got a tweet here from
jeremy from the quartering and he said
something that we don't want people to
see so
we're going to send you out the url's
mass text everybody report it right now
we'll get taken down
it doesn't take much too it takes like
maybe 20 or 30 reports within a certain
timeframe yeah if it's
short in a short period and because
conservatives don't do that because they
don't care
yeah it's typically conservatives that
are getting the getting the band hammer
ben white says i knew i recognized that
voice been a while since you were struck
by a claw
oh yeah clawstruck was used to be my
channel oh really i used to go with my
wife and like
we would get all hammered and then the
crane games yeah yeah oh yeah you used
to win them all the time
that was quite i mean i was that was
pretty good i was on the today show but
i decided to
say that i don't want to brag but yeah
michael nguyen says tim you need to
reach out to michael malus and get tom
woods on your show so you can have a
real libertarian on rather than someone
who calls themselves a libertarian is
nothing of the sort
that's a true libertarian who wrote that
i know right
yeah you know you know the the willy
meme no
damn libertarians they ruined
libertarianism yeah
yeah yeah
let's see x uh excel
accelerate says next episode of tim cast
will feature ghastly dope
fright supremacy is the right supremacy
the quartering agrees
oh yeah gastly it's a another youtube
channel yeah
frights fright supremacy is like their
uh catchphrase fright
supremacy what do they do is like
horicon or something no no it's just
ghastly is the name of the channel oh
okay yeah yeah timothy peterson says
greetings from the wisconsin gun deer
season
not sure if true but heard we will be
the world's sixth largest army during
these nine days
oh wow yeah the hunt yeah and everyone
goes out
there's two there are two bucks that
were pulled out of my the
uh my new land this morning this morning
i'll be uh hunting there next week too
oh really awesome numbers are up because
people are looking for a reason to go
out
yeah yeah deer deer take registrations
up great to see take your kids
how do they know they didn't kill too
many no such thing really deers are
deer are like a huge pest in wisconsin
yeah yeah
what yeah that's crazy well the problem
is right if you don't manage the herd
how do they die yeah nothing kills them
right no wolves
no what kills them is cars you know and
then people die dude
you know right that's messed up yeah so
that we have that problem out here
right you saw a couple of them on the
side of the road yeah i'm used to it you
know like
you can almost predict when you're gonna
see one but yeah yeah like
fathers mothers take your kids hunting
teach them how to harvest a deer
the hobbies dying and uh it's you know
hey i heard that if you eat their heart
you gain their courage oh is that true
that's
all i do is yeah yeah i have i don't
encourage you i don't think they're very
courageous
they're not greatest at all maybe the
boss yeah yeah i also eat their
testicles yeah that works too yeah
yeah yeah i don't know if it works or
not but no
no no worries but it tastes great it
hasn't not worked but it's uh
but it's a delicious snack and it's a
great way to stay in shape wow
right yeah yeah i hear it's one of the
main ingredients in brain force i'm not
sure
says literally two of the youtubers i've
binged in the beginning of march that
have been my favorite youtubers to view
absolutely love the work both of you do
lids and ian included keep up the great
work guys
but uh ian's chair is currently
unoccupied
and we have that conversation about
money yeah no it's just one chance to
the federal reserve he blew it yeah
he blew it
gage wampler says all this super chat
talk and i thought y'all were right
here's for the last five i should have
given that's right yeah you uh
super attack glory says i'm attractive
on the inside i can tell i can
feel already you've been more attractive
now
all these we got a ton of super chats
when we said that like people were like
start throwing money hey
i'm i was the first person to give a
super chat hey my dms are open hit me up
that's right well they're all very
attractive don't worry yeah i know
somebody somebody doesn't like you they
said oh awesome mgb says hambly is
actually the worst
profited from a video full of lies and
nonsense about me defending a piece of
crap and a crook trying to sell a lotus
with a fake signature
absolutely deserved the strike against
his channel whoa
that's an old magic the gathering yeah
reference
no idea interesting a lotus with a fake
signature
so you so you confess i confess i don't
know who they are but i'm getting here
yeah
i apparently uh and if if it was uh on
sleeve media days
i assure you i didn't make any money i
love i love i love twitter so much but
man you know there are some there are
some people
so you know stick sex and emory yeah
yeah i know he tweeted this funny meme
where it was like he always makes these
funny paintbrush memes yeah and it was
like this guy with a sickle and hammer
and he said something like i'm just an
innocent so
you know sock dem i you know but here
check out how awesome marks is and
communism
yeah yeah yeah shun had tweeted so true
with a bunch of exclamation points
and so i responded so you admit it which
is a very obvious and like old joke
obviously knows yeah yeah but her
followers
died they're the worst yeah unstoppable
and they were like oh no tim the thrill
i'm like dude
the so you admit it is an old yeah dry
like not even original joke yeah it's
like from from
futurama or something respect to shu but
yeah her sims are
legitimate but i was just like what she
she was joking i was joking it's twitter
it's okay yeah you know
you know what the issue is though it's
like the people who don't like her or
don't like you or don't like me often
don't watch our content and they oh yeah
most of the time
what will happen is someone's like a
clip of shu from it from a show
and then be like ah and then people take
clips of me from a show
and that's all the exposure these people
get right so they don't actually know so
like when we had we we had vashon bless
you
a bunch of these lefties were like oh
that was tim actually was that was kind
of cool i disagree with him
and i'm like yo maybe if you watched my
videos you'd be like oh i get it i get
that with my thumbnails like my
thumbnails
are baby admittedly but hey
that's the game you know what i mean
like i make no apologies for it it's
like i lie in them but
i can tell people when they screech
about like certain arguments i'm making
like oh you just see my thumbnails
you didn't actually watch it kind of the
other thing too is like uh definitely
thumbnails because
if the framing there's a bunch of
different there's always framing and my
framing is always based on like my
opinions of what i think is the most
important thing or what i care about
personally
right so like you know do you know hotep
you you know how tough jesus
yeah we had him on the show again two
thousand subscribers for the shout out
thank you you did yeah oh snap oh red
good point yeah yeah just make sure you
actually watch if you sub because it's
you know
but yeah right i asked totef what he
thought about republicans he was like i
don't know what they're doing to like
you and like mention about him or
something and i'm like exactly right
right right right like
i've complained about him a lot but it's
really hard to make a definitive
statement when they don't do anything
and i'm not saying i'm not saying
anything bad i'm saying literally
anything
yeah name a republican like uh
a bill that's been passed in the last
three years man i mean i'm sure there
are some i'm sure there are but like i
can't
yeah what did they do they oppose the
democrats
yeah exactly no for real you know like
that's it yeah
i i can give the democrats respect for
this they're trying to do things
i don't like the things they're trying
to do right that's why it's more
interesting to talk about like people
people think like oh you you know people
say to me all the time you know like
oh you never roast trump or you never do
this about the republicans i'm like
they're not
there's nothing interesting going on you
want me to get upset about a trump tweet
well that's not my content like i don't
care
yeah like if he's actually doing
something that i'm you know i got pissed
when he
when he was early in his pr uh
presidency he fired some missiles into
syria that pissed me off i was like bro
i literally voted you because you said
no more of this [ __ ]
yeah and then he like quickly figured
out and he never did people don't like
that stuff
yeah maxell says tim
would you be willing to moderate a
debate between vosh and the quartering
uh in person and uh here
but i also think that's fair to wash
because we clearly agree on a lot of
things
yeah yeah and we clearly wouldn't be
impartial plus i have no interest in
talking to a guy who makes a case that
there's no moral
moral reason well to be fair
yeah is you know he his response to that
was that he made a very poor
choice of words and trying to explain
philosophical position okay
you know my response to that is the the
the hardcore trump supporters are
absolutely like trying to use
that against me and i'm like dude i
bring people like alex jones has been
accused of a bunch of things i have
conversations with people
if you got an issue take it up with him
yeah i really i'm not a i'm not a
this is um you know there's this bygone
debate me bro era of youtube that i've
just
like have zero and i have zero interest
in yeah no thank you even when it was
popular it was never a debate it was
just two people screaming at each other
right exactly it was so dumb but it
still exists they're like
tim poole says leftists won't debate him
but then like when they offer to debate
him he ignores him i'm like dude i've
never asked anyone to debate me
not me either i don't want to debate
anybody if i've ever said it it was
ironic i have zero interest in
and by the way none of these people
actually know what debate means it's
just a
rhetoric contest and that's right it's
about who can own the other person with
more
you know oh just it's just generating
sound bites yeah i'm not interested in
it so they'll like have a pre-planned
sound bite
they won't actually be talking to you
and it's like this is a waste of time
yeah exactly like
i had a conversation with uh uh when i
was having
with respect i think david peckman's an
are a pretty good dude and i think he
does a
you know good job though i disagree with
him but when we were talking it felt
more like he was just trying to throw
semantic arguments as like gotcha
yeah it's so boring specifically when
and i got this from
vosh and i got this from cedar it's like
i get it all the time and i like with
wash i actually you know explained it
when i say something like identity
politics i'm using a colloquial
understanding of what of what this means
and we're specifically referring to
authoritarian application of
intersectionality right
if you take issue with the phrase
identity politics let me clarify and
break down what actually means but they
don't
let you no they're like no no you said
it you said it
right i'm like dude the civil rights
movement was identity politics and it
was a good thing right
but telling white people to go on
retreats to disavow themselves is not a
good thing and calling for segregation
is not a good thing
what's the stuff that they have what do
they call it in the government um
critical race critical race theory like
identity politics that's bad
right you know you know so literally one
of the tenets of it is that
white whiteness is a form of currency
that only white people possess what's
the original sin
in a lot of yeah it's it's it's it's
racist it's absurd
and it it basically creates segregation
and division and i'm not for it
and so when i'm talking about social
justice wars i'm talking about that
stuff
right but then it's like but you then
say you're mixed race i'm like
in the context of you claiming that
i have less privilege than you therefore
you should listen to me i say that
right and then you're ignore it and then
that proves my point that you don't
actually care
you just want power right right but it's
really difficult to have uh discussions
with mine on the left because whenever i
do
it becomes a semantic debate which is
it's so bold i'm just like
there's nothing more boring than that
period but go on sorry no it's like they
they they're
instead of saying i get what you mean
what so
it would be like if you say something
say let me clarify are you saying this
that and this
you're oh you're saying this that and
this okay i get it okay based on that
i'll say this
they don't do they go aha you said a
word now i gotta find that yeah get
wrecked
but i don't debate anyway like so we we
actually are gonna have uh oppressive on
in the next week or so an actual
progressive candidate who's running two
weeks yeah
and i think it's gonna be a great
conversation i think we're gonna
disagree and i'm really curious to see
how it goes because like when someone
says to me that healthcare is a human
right
i got a bunch of questions to ask yeah
yeah right yeah right
i never i've never gotten a satisfactory
answer uh to it
i like the idea personally of universal
healthcare yeah sure yeah
i think i think if it was if we i think
if we could guarantee
universe functional universal healthcare
to everybody that doesn't
destroy the economy or jack of prices
everybody would probably be like oh yeah
you know
if it's like a great of course it seems
like many of these leftists just think
you can snap your fingers and do it well
i always think it's funny when every
time it comes up i say uh ask lauren
chen how universal healthcare worked for
her dad's cancer
oh he had to fly to united states
america i
i needed to fly here to save his life oh
yeah okay enjoy your universe without
without revealing too many personal
details there's someone uh i've known
for a very long time who had to deal
with that as well
that in canada they didn't have access
and they had to come to the united
states but the problem is
when you've got someone who's very sick
you can't come to the united states
travel is too difficult but if they just
lived here then they'd be in the
hospital in and out
yeah yeah they might be broke but
they'll be alive
yeah that's that's it's it's it's uh
you know the challenge i say is when
they say healthcare is a human right i
say okay
there was a story about a louisiana kid
and he had a disease a genetic disease
there's a cure for this costs a million
dollars
you know why it's extremely hard to
produce and we don't have there's no
mass demand for it probably either
exactly
so the materials the production the
knowledge the know-how is extremely rare
because it's an extremely rare disease
do we say everyone has a right to a
million dollar treatment
yeah right that's tough yeah who's
paying for all the r d right that even
created it but who's going to do the
work to make it
nobody there's no incentive there's
there it's there lies the big problem
and i was talking to someone i said dude
health care can't be human right because
we
haven't cured every disease yet right
that means
we literally can't treat some things but
i do think we've talked
we definitely talked about it um what
what is it called like uh
when you break your hand or break your
leg like urgent care yeah yeah
yeah that should be that should be uh it
is very affordable
it is yeah well my i'm i'm totally down
if we if we
figure out a way to implement some kind
of care for emergency cases
if you get if your kid is the flu and
needs like a tamiflu or something really
quickly because they're in serious
we should we can take care of that what
you do what
yeah i had to go to the emergency room
one time and i was like i'm sorry i
don't have the money i work in a call
center and they didn't charge you
they did not charge me a single penny oh
there you go yeah looks like we got a
pretty good system well the way the law
is that they can't turn you away
right right so yeah it is kind of a
problem of course
yeah i think we could all agree that
healthcare could be significantly better
of course um but yeah that's a different
topic for a different day
we should start with that earlier yeah
jesse demarco says jeremy is a stand-up
guy
i own fire and dice a store that was
canceled by w
uh wizard of the coast in 2018 he was
the only on online voice willing to
stand up against cancel culture and his
gofundme was a real moral boost
for our loyal community paying it
forward and uh that was that was a
little tech flag yep they're like a
little kick flag in a pot somewhere
that's so insane man
wizards of course man i went to a game
shop
and they had a bunch of weird
intersectional
symbols and i was just like i'm not
going to
listen you know i was talking to a guy
and i said if i go to a place and i see
a trump flag
you know what the worst case scenario is
worst case scenario
what i get into an argument with a guy
about some oh right
right i see these like far leftist
symbols you know the worst case scenario
is yeah you get beat up
you get into it yeah or or they try and
cancel you they posting like they harass
you
yeah yeah and then the crazy thing is
the stop the shop stopped carrying magic
altogether
oh well and i'm like then what is this
place it's like it's really weird
yeah really space yeah yeah safe space
well maybe having all that crap up
made people feel unwelcome you know i
mean yeah exactly yeah killed their own
business
dube mcnasty says boom and thanks for
the super chat that's a
very beautiful super chat super chat
let's see what we got here
we have a bunch of super chats but uh
there we go gar hunt says matthew mercer
pulled out of an online stream because
he was playing an asian character
stating you should not role play other
races meanwhile his
his voice acting asian characters
discussed um matthew mercer
as an asian person okay i am speaking
for all asians right now
every single one i am extremely offended
yeah and all mixed-race people yeah oh
yeah
i believe i am calling on his company to
uh immediately terminate
and i'm kidding well how come all those
people that voice act for the simpsons
don't don't have yellow skin
you know oh that's an issue right that's
a good point yeah i guess no actually i
think that's one way around it
yeah right yeah i think it was family
guy that made the joke
when when when they did the crossover
that someone said everyone there had
jaundice or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's true yeah
robert stratton says thanks to both
jeremy and tim for doing what you do
jeremy i know you don't like politics
and games
i helped fund exclusively games but
check out republic
it is doubly subversive all right i'll
check it out yeah
matthew stockhausen says interesting
show with bree's biggest fan
the fence sitter and queen lids oh yeah
why are they saying your biggest because
you did a bunch of videos about it yeah
yeah
it's so funny because i did too yeah and
it was really weird how people were like
i can't believe tim's doing another
video about brie larson
and most of my videos were like with
respect you know she can do her thing i
got no issue
my complaint with captain marvel was
that i thought she was poorly cast yeah
and that's yeah it wasn't her fault i
thought robin wright would have been way
better as carol danvers
yeah i mean there's a whole bunch of
them you know but ultimately now it's
become a meme on my channel where i like
do extra videos
because people get super super mad yeah
yeah and then people just watch
because it's funny they hate watch yeah
yeah death trout says super chatters are
the best looking people
tim's going after a rakita log grift
king title
that's true it is it is a scientific
fact
i've never seen anything to disprove it
that's correct i've not either
yeah yeah yeah i've not seen the faces
of the people giving me the super chats
i'm sure they're very attractive though
i know they are yeah
w 50 000 what currency is w
love love from south carolina korea wow
yeah
thanks man amazing south korea
uh i don't know what kind of oh there it
is doobie mcnasty says jeremy informed
me of playstation reporting hong kong
citizens
oh playstation reporting hong kong
citizens yeah
yeah william bright says lynn wood got a
subpoena going for his lawsuit in
georgia against secretary of state oh
interesting very interesting
spicy yeah elusive gator says tim was
very surprised with alex jones with all
the conspiracy theories
the topic of queue was never brought up
you should bring a q researcher on your
show
uh didn't didn't it came out it came up
yeah you guys talked about it yeah yeah
yeah yeah and alex was he was kind of
disparaging wasn't he said he's he
disparaged the group basically
yeah yeah yeah he kind of yeah yeah i
remember that it was really interesting
to see like you know sitting down with
alex the difference between when he's
obviously doing a bit
yeah and when he's seriously talking
about something and he he said something
like the q
people are just what did he say was like
they're they're really hopeful and they
just want to believe
yeah all this yeah it's like that's
interesting coming from alex because
that's like a
good way to put it you know yeah
insightful yeah it's a safe way to put
it you know
oh we just jumped no andrea says any
bets as to how long it will take until
the dems and left re
over voting biden they already are they
are yeah it's amazing how many leftists
are already going like that joe biden oh
can you believe he's putting lobbyists
on his transition team
yes yeah i literally can i said he was
going baby
well you did that video too with the the
bite and regret like instant right
regret like it's like this is the dude
okay no more trump it was naomi
if i had known biden was for lockdowns i
wouldn't have voted for him how could
you not know
i've read it yeah on the debate stage
trump was screaming he's the lockdown
candidate yeah
but they they only watch these
mainstream news channels that just want
to feed them
the refuse man yeah that's the crazy
thing it's like i have these people
saying
there's people that are so blinded by
the mainstream news outlets or they
don't read news at all
and and look they watch youtube clips
with respect to vosh coming on the show
he did not know a lot about what was
going on with the durham report the
durham investigation yeah yeah
and so it's like i'm not that i expect
him to know everything
but that you can tell if someone says
trump is a despot because he fired comey
and you're like do you know why fired
comey
well i don't know it's probably
important that you do yeah
and i'm not saying that that means i'm
not saying he's ignorant of everything
he talks about i'm just saying in that
particular instance
maybe that's the reason why you don't
like trump because you don't know that
he had good reason to fire some of these
people well
yeah there were plenty of good reasons
to get rid of comey oh yeah i got plenty
yeah he's terrible and i just let
remember his like
he posted a selfie on twitter by the way
who the hell cares about you now that
you're not there
because like his biden mug and his butt
oh my god dude
yeah the establishment yeah go away
religion carl flynn says yes
carl flynn says first ever super chat
just got back from deployment for some
reason youtube wouldn't let me use yen
in any case god bless you all and keep
speaking the truth welcome back i
appreciate it
thank you for your service shadman says
two of my favorite youtubers the beanie
and the beard
wonderful conversation to watch yeah
yeah all right yeah
this is used to be a regular thing yeah
it's better than weenie in the butt
yeah what was that family guy yeah
weenie in the butt
turn the turn the knob off and rip it
off
spidge bandersnatch says i'd love a
video walk through your facility in your
music studio
will you commit to that right now isn't
that worth 15 call it pre-monetization
there's not really anything to show
right now i mean yeah we haven't we
haven't uh we're gonna start vlogging
and then you'll probably get a better
better picture but for now it's like we
have just like a spot where we do the
studio
a spot where we skate well there's a vip
area i saw you posted a picture of it
in the skate park yeah you probably got
video of me doing the uh the backflip
yeah yeah the 900 yeah the 900 shirtless
yeah yeah yeah that's definitely on
youtube so the vlog
on the clips yeah the vip section is on
top of the six foot half pipe
and if you can get up at your vip
everybody basically can it's super hard
it helps when you're six five
yeah definitely you just put your hand
up and it's like
but then if you can't then you're you're
you're uh you're relegated to the
nether lounge is underneath it by the
let's see nelson neville says
why is cultural appropriation considered
bad but gender appropriation is
encouraged
degenerative things good unifying things
bad good questions
gender appropriation yes what would you
call that what would you think what do
you think is referring to gender
appropriation
like uh i like men dressing like drag
shows
oh okay yeah that's a fair question ask
somebody who supports it yeah
armor wing says uh talking about the
need for our healthcare and not being
able to turn people away
there's a lot of hospital beds here in
el paso full of coveted patients from
mexico my aunt died alone in the
hospital bed over there
wow man yeah that sucks
all right let's see logan matthews says
you touched on an important point
incentive taking a look at human
behavior and incentive is important to
uncovering the root of the problem we
see
interesting yeah and i'll take well
let's do uh two more let's do two more
the killer critic says will they rig
this in 2022 should i bother voting
yes please vote please i'll probably end
up voting in 2022. you gotta vote you
can't just give up
but pay attention to candidates don't do
it tim don't like don't get black peeled
on me bud don't
you gotta you gotta like look for
candidates that are going to
i will say if you believe the widespread
voter fraud narrative is true
then you probably also believe how
dramatic and desperate they were
fighting back
so i think there is a threshold to where
if you get enough
votes it breaks the system so if you're
that worried request a mail and ballot
it takes you like 30 seconds to do it
from home and mail it in and move on
with your life
like literally it takes like well drop
it off because a lot of
you drop it off in a box a lot of the
republican absolute ballots according to
voter integrity fund never got received
mine still says in wisconsin i did um
early in person
it still says it hasn't been counted wow
now they say they have up to 45 days to
to update that but i'm like well what's
the point
then because the election's over yeah
like maybe you should it's all automated
i'm sure they could do some api like oh
they're scary that's the crazy thing
about our election system is that
the founding fathers should have given
several months
because how do you even investigate
impropriety
like not even fraud like someone making
a mistake how do you even have time to
investigate they're like you get a
couple weeks
well remember 2016 they called it the
same day yeah
you know like well the media likes to do
that yeah all right here's the last one
snack a13 says an army marches on its
belly napoleon and frederick the great
a hungry man really only fights for food
could the lockdowns be a tool for
hindering
our ability to defend the constitution
through hardship in some cases
well won't that make uh oh i see i see
what you're saying
i don't know it's a yeah i mean it's a
who knows it's a dangerous hole to go
down to when you start thinking about
like
some of the really nefarious stuff that
that you know
people talk about with the government
and what they're doing to control people
but
i think that the lockdowns will bring
more people together and will galvanize
people
against the ruling class which would be
good i think you're right yeah i think
in 2022
they're actually projecting republicans
are going to take back control yeah
because i think that they just won the
state legislatures
democrats won none so probably have
gained more control which means more
republican gerrymandering
yeah so they're going to hold right well
they're going to create more
opportunities for republicans to gain
distress that's what i'm sorry yeah
that's what i mean yeah yeah well jeremy
thank you for hanging out
yeah i really appreciate you guys having
me on lydia thank you so much
tim thank you hey to the crowd thanks uh
tim for not telling me how many people
are in there so i didn't have to send
after a full-blown panic attack
in yeah but i appreciate you you uh
having me
yeah for sure dude yeah thanks for
having me well if if you haven't already
smash
the like button right now smash it press
it it really does help and uh hit the
notification bell subscribe we do the
show monday through friday live at 8pm
tomorrow is going to be a big
and consequential show apparently i'm
hoping so i mean sometimes guess cancel
that's why i'm not going to announce
exactly what it is but
it could have an impact uh discussion
where we're going to have i believe will
absolutely have an impact on the
elections
it's going to be some serious litigation
so we'll uh we're going to have a
we're we're gonna have somebody talking
about some stuff that could affect
everything looking if tim's show's not
on i mean you can always subscribe to
the quartering
that's right if his internet goes down i
mean
i do like what i don't i have tim pool
levels of output
six seven videos a day yeah yeah so uh
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and parlor that's tim cast my
other channels are youtube.comtimcast
and youtube.comtimcast.irl
which i put uh i'm sorry tim cass news
this is tim kessler
but i get three channels you put content
all day but uh you can also check out uh
jeremy yes please do quartering of mid
wesley the quartering
you need to break a million subs yeah
i'm very close i'm so i can taste it
they're gonna they're gonna they've done
it to so many people i'm not gonna jinx
i know i know what you're about to say
well that's what they did to me in
november so i'm hoping that you know
break on through here
break on through and then and then they
begrudgingly give you the gold
they may not there's more and more
people just aren't getting the award
i know somebody who's got hundreds of
thousands and youtube basically told
them the f off
they're like we don't like you we've
never liked it we're not giving you the
award yeah
for me they were like we're gonna send
you two right well yeah you're tim poole
i mean
yeah you've got some missing bricks up
front you just put these down on the
ground
yeah so i actually i have two channels
that cracked a million
this channel is like 150 away or so
but uh i ended up getting two for some
reason that's weird like they just
two came from well i'm like all right
you know here we go i got two
yeah we all have none you know so well
guys
yeah so uh the quartering on youtube and
you're very close so uh yeah man but
definitely come back
uh and of course you can follow lydia
you can you can follow us our patch lids
on twitter oids
and uh the chair is empty inside here is
empty but
we do have take that federal reserve
yeah
we should create it we should create a
twitter account for the [ __ ] you should
just have a live stream
for the plant seriously you don't know
what you know what i really want to do i
want to dedicate an entire room to
several guinea pigs
and just turn a live camera on 24 7.
dude did you ever watch the hamster guy
no oh my let me tell you my friend
it's it's i think it's called hampshire
or something some chat will probably
know
hamster no but he has all these hamsters
living
under water and he has like all these
projects and he's like a patreon
yeah it's like it's like it's like the
the the the hamster house is under the
water so they're in it walking around
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's wholesome
wholesome content maybe they'll be fun
stuff yeah
all right we're going to be back
tomorrow at 8 p.m live with a very very
big and very important consequential
show that's why i'm not going to say
i'm not going to say right now that i
think trump is down and out just yet but
i'll admit with this he's down but he's
not out
not yet yeah the transition thing to me
sounds like he's preparing
you know he's recognizing but there's
gonna there's there's some pending
litigation which could be very very uh
consequential we'll be talking about
tomorrow with this
special special guest so uh thanks for
hanging out and we will see you all
tomorrow at 8 pm live
bye guys
you